[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव प्लीज लेट मी नो
एवरीबॉडी इफ आई एम लाइव एंड इफ आई एम
ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली
प्लीज लेट मी नो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते
गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते टू ऑल ऑफ यू अ वेरी
वेरी गुड इवनिंग एंड नमस्ते टू सभी को
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए जल्दी-जल्दी सभी को आ जाने देते हैं।
एक बार फटाफट
सभी को ज्वाइन कर लेने देते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नितेश सर किधर इधर इधर आई एम इधर
ऑडियो बिल्कुल क्लियर है सभी को एक बार
बता दीजिए ऑडियो बिल्कुल क्लियर है ना कोई
ऑडियो में तो कोई इशू नहीं आ रही है
लेट मी नो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नो इशू ठीक है बहुत बढ़िया
[खांसने की आवाज़]
बहुत बढ़िया
ओके सभी को एक बार ज्वाइन कर लेने देते
हैं। देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग एंड आज से
क्योंकि एक नई टॉपिक एक नई सेगमेंट आपका
स्टार्ट हो रहा है फॉर दिस एसओसी एल1 फ्री
जॉब रेडी लाइव ट्रेनिंग क्लास 19 है ये
एंड एक अलग ही
टॉपिक्स जो है एक सेगमेंट जो है वो हमारा
स्टार्ट होने वाला है। विल बी स्टार्टिंग
एंड इसको आप स्टार्टिंग से शुरू कर सकते
हैं। अगर आपने पहले के क्लासेस नहीं भी
देखे हैं तो भी आप यह जो वीडियो है यह जो
क्लास है वो आप देख सकते हैं। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है क्योंकि बिल्कुल नया है
एंड हटके टॉपिक्स हैं। ओएस वाला पार्ट
स्टार्ट करेंगे हम आज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] से।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सर फाइनली गॉट
क्लियर्ड फ्रॉम द कॉलेज एंड ऑल अब से डेली
अटेंडेंस सर। क्या बात है। बहुत बहुत
अच्छी बात है। अगर आप डेली अटेंडेंस करने
वाले हैं तो।
दैट्स गुड।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
एआई इंप्लीमेंटेशन कराना सिखाइए।
सिखाएंगे। बिल्कुल बिखि बिल्कुल सिखाएंगे।
एकदम बेफिक्र रहिए।
सब सीखेंगे हम। सब देखेंगे। बस आप बने
रहिए इस ट्रेनिंग में। एंड मुझे एक बार
जल्दी से बता दीजिए सभी लोग क्योंकि यहां
पे ऑलमोस्ट सभी लोग आ चुके हैं। कुछ लोग
अभी भी नहीं आए हैं। अटेंड नहीं कर रहे
हैं। तो सबको आ जाने देते हैं। एक बार सभी
लोग मुझे एक बार यह बता दीजिए कि
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आप में से कितने लोग ऐसे हैं अभी यहां पे
करेंटली जो अभी इस क्लास में प्रेजेंट हैं
जो डे वन से क्लास वन से अभी तक कंटिन्यूड
हैं। हो सकता है बीच में एक दो क्लासेस
आपने स्किप कर दी हो। दैट वुड बी फाइन। बट
मोस्टली आपने सारी क्लासेस लाइव जो हैं
अटेंड करी हैं। आप में से कितने लोग हैं?
या फिर ऐसे भी लोग जिन्होंने अभी तक पूरी
क्लासेस देख ली है चाहे लाइव या
रिकॉर्डिंग और आप अभी इस लाइव क्लास में
हैं। आप में से कितने लोग हैं? मुझे एक
बार बता दो एक बार। जस्ट आई जस्ट वांट टू
टेक एन आईडिया ऑफ इट। हाउ मेनी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ऑफ यू आर हियर
ऑफ़ देम?
मी मी ओके। इट्स ऑलरेडी 3 मंथ्स। हाउ मेनी
मोर सेशंस विल ऑलरेडी बता दिया है मैंने
कितना टाइम लगेगा क्या लगेगा सो करते जाइए
बस फिलहाल
कंट
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम
मी ओके काफी लोग हैं ठीक है कंप्लीटेड ऑल
सेशन ओके ठीक है आई विल कंप्लीटेड ऑल द
क्लास डे फर्स्ट ठीक है अच्छी बात है चलिए
तो काफी लोग हैं जो लाइक अभी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अ लाइक दे आर फ्रॉम वेरी स्टार्टिंग एंड
अभी भी कंटिन्यूड है। बहुत अच्छी बात है।
अच्छा लगा देख के। आई होप कि आप लास्ट तक
इसी तरह से कंटिन्यू रहेंगे एंड इस सेशन
को साथ में एंड करेंगे हम। राइट? चलिए
बिफोर वी स्टार्ट एज यू नो कि हर जो भी
आपकी क्लासेस होती हैं सिंपल आपका सिंपल
सिंपल [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] फंडा है।
आपको डेफिनेड YouTube चैनल पे तो जाना है
लाइव सेक्शन में। एंड जो ये वीडियोस हैं
एसओसी की क्लासेस की जो भी प्रीवियस कोई
भी वीडियो को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। एंड यहां पे
आप जब एक्सपेंड करेंगे इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन
वीडियो का तो दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे। दोनों
लिंक को ओपन कर लेना है आपको। पहला दूसरा
WhatsApp का एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का एसओसी
का स्पेशल ग्रुप है। स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप है।
सारे नोट्स रिसोर्सेज आने वाले अपकमिंग
सर्टिफिकेशन के बारे में, इंटर्नशिप्स के
बारे में या फिर जो भी हमारी एक इंटरव्यू
प्रिपरेशन होगी सबको सब चीजों की डिटेल्स
आपको इसी ग्रुप में मिलने वाली है। एंड द
नेक्स्ट इज़ WhatsApp चैनल। हमारी इस एसओसी
की हो या किसी भी अदर ट्रेनिंग कोर्सेज
रिसोर्सेज कुछ भी हो सबसे पहले आपको यहां
पे ओवरऑल अनाउंसमेंट्स एंड डिटेल आपको
यहां मिल जाते हैं। तो ये दोनों को एक को
ग्रुप को जॉइ करना है और चैनल को फॉलो कर
लेना है। ये Lindin की प्रोफाइल है मेरी।
आप मुझसे यहां पे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं।
मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मेरे काम को फॉलो
कर सकते हैं। टेक्निकल नेविगेटर। साथ ही
में आप जब सर्च करेंगे डेफ्रोनिक्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे
यू विल सर्च द डिफ्रronics तो आपको
डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी का Lindin पेज
मिल जाएगा। आप इस Lindin पेज पे जाके आप
हमारे इस पेज को फॉलो करके हमारी कंपनी की
जो अपडेट्स हैं, कंपनी की जो डिटेल्स है,
कंपनी की जो भी अपकमिंग हमारे हम जो भी
चीजें कर रहे हैं कंपनी के थ्रू व्हाटएवर
वी आर डूइंग व्हाटएवर अपडेट्स इज़ देयर
आपको यहां पे मिल जाएंगे। तो यहां पे लगभग
22,000 लोग हमसे ऑलरेडी जुड़ चुके हैं। तो
आप इसका पार्ट बन चुके बन सकते हैं। एक
डिफ्रॉनिक्स स्टर बन सकते हैं। ये हमारा
एक्स पेज है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल से।
आप यहां पे 600 प्लस फॉलोवर्स के साथ जुड़
सकते हैं हमसे। आने वाले टाइम में इस पे
बहुत कुछ आने वाला अपडेट्स एंड पोस्ट्स
आपको देखने को मिलेंगी। यह Instagram पेज
जो मेरी पर्सनल पेज है पर्सनल एक खुद का
प्रोफाइल है। आप इस पे आके मुझसे कनेक्ट
हो सकते हैं। मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मेरे
लाइफ जो भी अपडेट्स है उसके साथ कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं। यह हमारी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी पेज
है। जहां पे आप आके साइबर सिक्योरिटी
एथिकल हैकिंग से रिलेटेड इनेशनल कंटेंट
आपको मिल जाएगा। रील्स वगैरह के थ्रू
शॉट्स वगैरह मतलब जो भी वीडियो ऑडियो के
थ्रू जो भी वीडियो एंड पेजेस के थ्रू
पोस्ट के थ्रू मिलती है। एंड दिस इज़ द
वेबसाइट दैट वी आर ऑपरेटिंग थ्रू एंड यहां
पे हमारा WhatsApp नंबर है। इस पे आप एनी
टाइम हमें जो है आप WhatsApp पे मैसेज कर
सकते हैं। क्वेरी पूछ सकते हैं। क्वेश्चंस
पूछ सकते हैं। एकडमी पे जाके हमारे
कोर्सर्सेस को हमारे तरफ से जो जो
कोर्सर्सेस हैं उसको एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं। कोर्सर्सेस को आप देख सकते हैं।
दैट्स इट। एंड जो भी कोर्सर्सेस के
सर्टिफिकेशन आपको मिलते हैं वेरीफाई
सर्टिफिकेट पे जाके आप यहां पे फर्स्ट नेम
सर्टिफिकेट आईडी डाल के उसको वेरीफाई एंड
डाउनलोड भी कर सकते हैं। तो ये पूरी चीजें
हो गई। अब हम आगे आज के जो टॉपिक है उस पे
जब चलते हैं तो आज की टॉपिक काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग एंड हटके है क्योंकि आज से हम
जो स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं वो है हमारा ओएस
का पार्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पार्ट। तो एज अ
एसओसी एल1 मैंने आपको पहले भी बोला था कि
एज अ एसओसी एल1 देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स
दैट यू शुड बी गोइंग थ्रू। ठीक है?
मल्टीपल कांसेप्ट्स हैं, मल्टीपल टॉपिक्स
हैं जिसके थ्रू आपको जाना है। उनके
कांसेप्ट्स को समझना है एंड देन आपका जो
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन वाला पार्ट होता
है वो भी हम कवर करेंगे। ये सारी चीजें
मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला हुआ था। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गौरव जहांगीर प्रेजेंट सर प्रेजेंट। बहुत
अच्छी बात है।
नो ऑडियो
ऑडियो आ रही है भाई आपकी आप आपके साइड चेक
कर लो आपके साइड कुछ इशू होगी बहुत टाइम
से मैं एसओसी के बारे में पढ़ना चाहती थी
और YouTube पर एसओसी के लिए सर्च कर रही
थी तभी आपने एसओसी ल्च कर दिया एंड इन
सबके लिए लॉट्स ऑफ थैंक्स यू आर वेलकम एंड
ग्लैड कि आप लोगों की हेल्प हो रहा है हो
पा रही है आप लोग इससे कुछ सीख पा रहे हैं
कुछ कर पा रहे हैं थैंक्स अ
नोट्स नोट्स बहुत मांगते हैं भाई। नोट्स
देखो नोट्स मैं WhatsApp ग्रुप में सबको
प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं। ऑलरेडी जो है
WhatsApp ग्रुप में आपको नोट्स तो मिल
जाते हैं। राइट? आपको नोट्स भेज दिए जाते
हैं। बट मैं फिर भी बोलता हूं खुद के
नोट्स बनाओ। ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। आप
अगर मेरे नोट्स पे डिपेंड रहेंगे तो उसका
कोई बेनिफिट नहीं होने वाला है। याद
रखिएगा। आप खुद के नोट्स जब बनाएंगे तो
आपका वो एक बार रिवीजन होता है। वापस से
एक बार आपका प्रैक्टिस होता है। बहुत आपके
दिमाग में वो चीजें बैठ जाएंगी लॉन्ग टर्म
के लिए। तो आपके लिए आपके जॉब रोल के लिए
आपके करियर के लिए काफी बढ़िया रहेगा।
दैट्स व्हाई आई से टू प्रिपेयर योर ओन ओन
नोट्स आल्सो राइट
हां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डीएचई भी
डीएई भी आने वाला है जल्दी ही स्टार्ट
होगा एंड हां एक चीज और आप सबको
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मैं बताना चाहता
हूं हमारा एक साइबर Intel जो प्लेटफार्म
है वो ल्च हो चुका है अगर आपको नहीं पता
तो आपको मैं यहां पे बता देना चाहता हूं
साइबर Intel जो भी लाइक इसमें जो भी एसओसी
हालांकि एसओसी से रिलेट ज्यादा कुछ इसमें
नहीं है। जो साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
से रिलेटेड लोग हैं, जो ओसिएंट से रिलेटेड
लोग हैं, जो एथिकल हैकिंग से रिलेटेड या
पेंटेस्टिंग या डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक से
रिलेटेड लोग हैं, वो इस प्लेटफार्म को यूज़
कर सकते हैं। साइबर intelfon.com
यहां पे आपको यह एक एडवांस ओसिएंट
इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफार्म है। यहां पे
हालांकि जब हमने अनाउंस किया था तो बहुत
ज्यादा लोड आ गई थी हमारे सर्वर पे। बहुत
सारे लोगों ने एक साथ इसको ब्राउज़ करना
शुरू किया था। तो काफी ज्यादा लोड आ गई
थी। बीइंग अ बिंग ऑन अ वीपीएस। वीपीएस भी
हमने यूज़ किया है। फिर भी उसकी भी एक एक
कैपेबिलिटी होती है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अह तो उसके
बाद भी लोड काफी बढ़ गया था। तो कई बार
दिक्कतें आई थी लोगों को साइन अप वगैरह।
अभी बिल्कुल सही है। आप इस पे आके अपने
यूजर पोर्टल पे अगर आप एलए से हैं, लॉ
इनफोर्समेंट एजेंसी से हैं, पुलिस में हैं
या ऐसे प्राइवेट इन्वेस्टिगेटर वगैरह हैं
तो आप एलए पोर्टल पे जा सकते हैं। एंड
यहां पे आप साइन अप कर सकते हैं। बट अगर
आप नॉर्मल यूजर हैं तो आपके लिए यूजर
पोर्टल है। यहां पे जाके आप साइन अप करके
लॉगिन करके क्रेडिट्स को आप बाय करके एंड
इसके सर्विज को यूज़ कर सकते हैं। सर्विज
कौन-कौन सी है? नीचे आप स्क्रॉल करेंगे तो
आपको यहां पे सारी सर्विज दिख जाएंगी। जो
भी इंटेलिजेंस सर्विज हम प्रोवाइड कर रहे
हैं वो सारी सर्विज के लिस्ट आपको यहां पे
दिख जाएगी। इन लिस्ट को देखिएगा एंड आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा। उसके बाद जब आप साइन अप
करके लॉग इन कर लेंगे देन आपको वहां पे
सारी सर्विज दिख जाएंगी। सर्विज को आप तभी
यूज़ कर पाएंगे व्हेन यू विल बी ऐडिंग द
क्रेडिट। क्रेडिट ऐड करके ही आप सर्विस
यूज़ कर पाएंगे। तो यहां पे जब क्रेडिट ऐड
करेंगे तो आपको वहां पे ₹5000 का दो ऑप्शन
मिलेगा और एक कस्टम का मिलता है। वहां पे
आप मिनिमम ₹100 का करके आप टेस्ट आउट कर
सकते हैं। सर्विज को देख सकते हैं हाउ इट
इज़ आपके काम की है कि नहीं। अगर आपके काम
की होगी आपके काम की लगेगी तो यू कैन गो
अहेड एंड आप अपना इसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
क्रेडिट जो आपको ऐड करेंगे आप वो लाइफट
वैलिड होगा। उसका कोई ऐसा लिमिटेशन नहीं
है कि एक महीने में खत्म हो जाएगी या कुछ
भी। जब आप यूज़ करेंगे तभी आपको यूज़ आएगा।
नहीं यूज़ करेंगे वैसे ही पड़ा रहेगा। सो
उसके लिए बेफिक्र रहना है कि क्रेडिट आपकी
खत्म हो जाएगी एक लिमिटेड टाइम में। राइट?
बस दैट्स इट। तो आप इसको ट्राई जरूर
कीजिएगा साइबर intel.fronic.com
इस प्लेटफार्म को।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो आज से हम एसओसी में जो चीज स्टार्ट कर
रहे हैं वो है हमारा ओएस पार्ट। OS इज़
आल्सो वेरीेंट वेरी वेरीेंट। बिकॉज़ ओएस
पार्ट जो है वो एक्चुअली आपके एसओसी का
बहुत इंटीग्रल पार्ट है कि Windows OS के
बारे में जानकारी लेना, थोड़ी लinक्स OS के
बारे में जानकारी लेना ये सब आपको जानकारी
चाहिए। क्योंकि आप जब एक फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ़
डिफेंस कहते हैं अपने आपको। आप जब फर्स्ट
लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस होते हैं किसी कंपनी के
अंदर में एक डिफेंसिव अप्रोच के थ्रू आप
अपने कंपनी के नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को
सेफगार्ड कर रहे होते हैं। उस केस में
क्या होता है कि आपको अगर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
से आपकी फैमिलियरिटी नहीं है। आप उतना
लाइक अच्छे से आप जानते नहीं ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के बारे में तो आप उस पे होने वाले
अटैक्स को भी प्रॉपर्ली जो है ना वो
क्लासिफाई नहीं कर पाएंगे। आप प्रॉपर्ली
जो है उसको जज नहीं कर पाएंगे। प्रॉपर्ली
आप उसको अच्छे से डील नहीं कर पाएंगे। सही
से आपको क्या काउंटर मेजर लेने चाहिए? किस
तरीके से लेना चाहिए? कहां पे अटैक हुआ
है। किस पार्ट पे अटैक हुआ है वो आप
डिसाइड नहीं कर पाएंगे। तो ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के बारे में बेसिक जानकारी रहनी
आपकी बहुत जरूरी है। मैं इस एसओसी
ट्रेनिंग में इस एसओसी एल1 ट्रेनिंग में
मैं आपको इस तरीके से पढ़ा रहा हूं, सिखा
रहा हूं कि आपकी हर एक एस्पेक्ट जो है ना
वो हम टच करते हुए चल रहे हैं। हर एक
पर्सन को टच करते हुए चल रहे हैं। ताकि कल
को आप जब इंटरव्यू के लिए जाओ या कहीं काम
करने जाओ, जॉब के लिए जाओ तो आपको हर चीज
के बारे में नॉलेज होनी चाहिए। हां। अब
आपके साइड से भी एक चीज़ हमारे को क्या
चाहिए होती है? एक चीज़ क्या होनी चाहिए कि
आप भी खुद से एक्सप्लोर करिए। ऐसा नहीं कि
बस आप यहां पे पढ़ लीजिए और घर पे जाके सो
जाइए। उसके बाद फिर नेक्स्ट क्लास का वेट
कीजिए। नेक्स्ट क्लास में आइए, पढ़ लीजिए।
फिर घर पे जाके सो जाइए। ऐसा नहीं होता।
ऐसे तो करने से तो फिर तो स्कूल में 50
100 बच्चे 100 बच्चे जब पढ़ते हैं क्लास
में 50 बच्चे पढ़ते हैं तो उसमें से अगर
ऐसे ही सब कोई करे तो कोई ना साइंटिस्ट
बनेगा ना डॉक्टर बनेगा। तो यार कुछ बात
होती है कुछ बच्चों में जो कुछ अलग कर कर
जाते हैं। लाइक कुछ अलग करके दिखाते हैं।
आपके अंदर भी वो बात हो सकती है बट करना
पड़ेगा। आपको ऐसा नहीं कि प्रोकस्टिनेट
नहीं करना है कि भैया अच्छा मैं कर लूंगा।
ऐसा नहीं करना। तो फिर आप कर सकते हैं।
बिल्कुल कर [हंसी] सकते हैं। जैसा मैंने
बोला मैं जॉब रेडी के अकॉर्डिंग ही इस
ट्रेनिंग को लेकर जा रहा हूं। तो
जैसे-जैसे मैं लेके जा रहा हूं वैसे-वैसे
आप करते जाइए। डेफिनेटली यू विल बी गेटिंग
द बेस्ट ऑफ द बेस्ट एंड जो क्वालिटी है।
ठीक है?
यू आर वेलकम गौरव।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] Finance कॉम।
कोई बात नहीं। आप एक बार फिर से लॉग इन
करके देखिएगा। अगर नहीं भी होगा तो आप
हमारे Telegram सपोर्ट चैनल जो है उस पे
आप हमें मैसेज कर लीजिएगा। जैसे आपको अगर
साइबर Intel में किसी को भी कोई इशू आता
है ना तो मैंने बताया भी था वीडियो
अनाउंसमेंट में तो इसी पेज पे आप सबसे
नीचे जाएंगे सबसे नीचे जब आप आएंगे तो
यहां पे आपको डिफ़ॉन डिफ़्रॉनिक्स साइबर
Intel सपोर्ट का एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा।
Telegram हैंडल मिलेगी। आप इस पे आके
ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा यहां पे। एंड यहां पे
आप हमसे अपने जो भी क्वेरीज है पूछ सकते
हैं। बताओ हम आपकी क्वेरीज को रिॉल्व कर
देंगे। ठीक है? साइबर Intel के लिए। चलिए
ओके।
सर आप डेली वीडियो लाइव करें क्योंकि आपका
वीडियो तीन-चार दिन में आता है तो
कंसिस्टेंसी
अ नहीं रहती है। देखो डेली तो नहीं आ
पाएगी पॉसिबल नहीं है। ठीक है? इट्स नॉट
पॉसिबल क्योंकि बहुत सारे काम होते हैं।
बहुत सारी चीजें होती है। एंड अदर थिंग्स
आई हैव टू आल्सो मैनेज। तो मैं बहुत मैनेज
करके सब कुछ लाता हूं। बट स्टिल बहुत
फ्रीक्वेंटली अब ला रहा हूं। पहले बीच में
गैप हुई थी। बट स्टिल आपसे जो चीजें मैंने
बोली थी वह तो आपने आप लोग नहीं कर पाते
हैं। बट स्टिल मैंने उसको इग्नोर किया
लेकिन कम से कम 100 प्लस कमेंट्स का तो
मैं अभी भी एक्सपेक्ट करता हूं। तो वो
चीजें तो आप करिए करिए लेकिन आपके वीडियोस
आती रहेंगी। आप बेफिक्र रहिए। ठीक है?
आपको थोड़ा अगर डिले या गैप लेके भी मिल
रहा है ना तो आपको बेस्ट मिलेगा। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे आज
हम जो है Windows आर्किटेक्चर Windows OS
से स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं। वी आर गोइंग थ्रू
द Windows आर्किटेक्चर एंड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] द Windows
रजिस्ट्री। इन दो चीजों के बारे में हम
समझेंगे, पढ़ेंगे।
आई होप [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कि
आपको डिस्प्ले पर पूरा क्लियर दिख रहा
होगा। आपको जो डायग्राम है उसके अंदर जो
चीजें लिखी हैं वो क्लियर दिख रहा है।
मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए। अगर नहीं भी दिख
रहा हो तो ज़ूम आप करेंगे। अपनी स्क्रीन को
पिंच ज़ूम करेंगे तो आपको दिख जाएगी
क्लियर। तो एक बार मुझे कंफर्म कीजिए। इफ
यू कैन सी द स्क्रीन यू कैन सी द इमेज एंड
उसके अंदर लिखी हुई चीजें आप आराम से देख
सकते हैं। इज इट विज़िबल?
प्लीज लेट मी नो क्लियर क्लियर
चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अच्छी बात
है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सो टुडे
वी आर गोइंग टू डील एंड स्टार्ट विद द
Windows आर्किटेक्चर। बेसिकली Windows
आर्किटेक्चर
में हम क्या चीज़ जानेंगे? हमको क्या पढ़ना
है? हमको क्या जानना है? Windows
आर्किटेक्चर के अंदर। हमें जानना है कि
प्रोसेससेस कैसे रन होते हैं? हमें जानना
है कि मेमोरी कैसे हैंडल होती है? हमें
जानना है कि यूजर कैसे ऑथेंटिकेट करते
हैं। हमें जानना है कि सिक्योरिटी कैसे
इनफोर्स होती है। बस ये चीजें हम Windows
आर्किटेक्चर के अंदर जानेंगे। आपका
Windows जो है उसके अंदर किस-किस चीजों
कौन-कौन सी चीजें किस तरीके से काम करती
है? उसको हमें जानना है। यही Windows
आर्किटेक्चर के अंदर हमें सीखना है। इसका
मतलब है एज एसओसी आपका यहां पे मेन रोल
क्या? मेन क्या है? वेयर अटैक हैपेंस?
अटैक एक्चुअली कहां हो रही है? इसके थ्रू
आपको यह समझ में आएगा। ये सब सारी चीजें
जब आप पढ़ लेंगे, सीख लेंगे तो आपको
एग्जैक्टली समझ में आएगा कि अटैक्स कहां
हो रही है। ठीक है? तो मैंने यहां पे एक
डायग्राम यहां पे आपके लिए दिया हुआ है।
ठीक है? यहां पे डायग्राम आपके लिए दिया
हुआ है। इस डायग्राम में आपको दिखेगा यहां
पे कुछ चीजें यहां पे दिख रही हैं। कुछ
कॉम्प्लेक्स चीजें दिख रही हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इस डायग्राम को
समझाने से पहले मैं आपको एक नेक्स्ट
डायग्राम पे ले जाऊंगा और यहां पे आपको
समझाऊंगा। इन चीज को समझाऊंगा। फिर उस
वाले डायग्राम पे आएंगे। आपको ज्यादा
क्लियर होगा। देखो Windows आर्किटेक्चर के
अंदर में दो तरह के मोड्स होते हैं। टू
टाइप्स ऑफ मोड्स। एक होता है यूजर मोड, एक
होता है कर्नल मोड। ठीक है? कर्नल मोड जो
होता है और यूजर मोड जो होता है, दोनों की
अपनी-अपनी कुछ अ फंक्शनैलिटीज हैं। उसमें
हम आएंगे। बट पहले मैं आपको रिंग से थोड़ा
सा फमिलियर [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कराता हूं। देखो, विंडोज आर्किटेक्चर के
अंदर में जब हम पढ़ते हैं ना, तो यहां पे
हम रिंग्स के बारे में पढ़ते हैं। तो देयर
आर थ्री रिंग्स। थ्री रिंग्स। थ्री का
मतलब नंबरिंग की बात मैं कर रहा हूं। वैसे
चार होंगे बट नंबरिंग में जीरो से स्टार्ट
करेंगे। थ्री तक रिंग्स होते हैं आपके। एक
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आपका रिंग
जीरो होता है। एक आपका रिंग वन होता है।
एक आपका रिंग टू होता है। एक आपका रिंग
थ्री होता है। इस तरीके से रिंग्स होते
हैं। अब इसका मतलब क्या है? जो रिंग ज़ीरो
होता है उसमें कर्नल ऑपरेट करता है। आपका
जो जो Windows कर्नल है ना या ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम कर्नल बोल लो व्हाटएवर। तो आपका जो
कर्नल है वो ऑपरेट करता है। एंड रिंग थ्री
जो सबसे लास्ट का रिंग है उसमें यूजर
ऑपरेट करता है। यूजर मोड होता है वो। यूजर
ऑपरेट का मतलब है यूजर रिलेटेड सर्विज
ऑपरेट होती है। कर्नल का मोड का मतलब होता
है कर्नल रिलेटेड सर्विसेज ऑपरेट होती है।
अब यहां पे इसका मतलब क्या है? रिंग 0 1 2
3 ये ऐसे इसका मतलब क्या है? ये इसका मतलब
व्हाट इज दिस? दिस इज़ दीज़ आर कॉल्ड
प्रोटेक्शन रिंग्स। इनको हम प्रोटेक्शन
रिंग्स बोलते हैं। दीज़ आर कॉल्ड
प्रोटेक्शन रिंग्स ये प्रोटेक्शन रिंग्स
कहलाते हैं। अब ये प्रोटेक्शन रिंग्स जो
है ना जीरो से थ्री तक होते हैं। सबसे जो
कोर में होता है ना सबसे कोर में जीरो वो
होता है सबसे हाईएस्ट प्रिविलेज वाला
एरिया। वहां पर वो चीजें ऑपरेट करती है जो
सबसे ज्यादा प्रिविलेज्ड होती हैं। उनके
पास प्रिविलेज सबसे ज्यादा होता है। उनके
पास परमिशन सबसे ज्यादा होती है। सबसे
ज्यादा चीजें होती है वो होता है रिंग
ज़ीरो। एंड रिंग थ्री जो होती है वो होता
है लिस्ट प्रिविलेज वाला। यानी कि सबसे कम
प्रिविलेज जिसके पास होती है वो रिंग थ्री
में ऑपरेट करता है। ठीक है? तो अब आप अपने
Windows में जो Microsoft Word यूज़ करते
हो, PT यूज़ करते हो या जो भी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस यूज करते हो, सॉफ्टवेयर्स
यूज़ करते हो वो सब लिस्ट प्रिविलेज वाले
होते हैं। वो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
रिंग थ्री में ऑपरेट करते हैं यूजर मोड के
अंदर में। बट जितने भी कर्नल रिलेटेड
एक्टिविटीज हो गई आपकी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
बूट अप जो होता है सिक्योरिटी कर्नल्स
होते हैं वो सारी चीजें जो आपके ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट होते हैं
काफी ज्यादा से उसने सिक्योरिटी के लिए
उनके फंक्शनैलिटीज के लिए इंपॉर्टेंट होते
हैं जिनके पास हाईएस्ट लेवल ऑफ़ प्रिविलेज
होना ही चाहिए तभी आप Windows को यूज़ कर
पाएंगे। आप अपने कंप्यूटर को स्टार्ट कर
पाएंगे। वो सारी चीजें रिंग ज़ीरो में
ऑपरेट करती है कर्नल मोड के अंदर में। तो
इस तरीके से ये रिंग वाली आर्किटेक्चर
होती है। ठीक है? अब
यहां पर इसका मतलब क्या होता है? मैं आपको
समझाता हूं। कर्नल मोड आपका अंदर की तरफ
होता है और यूजर मोड बाहर की तरफ होता है।
द व्हाट इट मींस प्रिविलेज की अगर बात हम
बात करें तो रिंग ज़ीरो में कर्नल मोड हो
गया। रिंग वन यूज़लेस है। मतलब यूज़लेस का
मतलब होता है कि रिंग ज़ीरो को रिंग वन को
यूज़ नहीं किया जाता। नॉट नॉट बीइंग यूज़्ड।
रिंग टू नॉट बीइंग यूज़्ड। एंड रिंग थ्री
में आपका यूजर आपका हो जाता है। जो यूजर
मोड होता है वो होता है। तो नीचे से अंदर
से बाहर की तरफ अगर हम जाते हैं तो मोस्ट
प्रिविलेज्ड से लिस्ट प्रिविलेज तक हम
हमारी सफर होती है। तो सबसे अंदर वाला जो
होता है रिंग ज़ीरो मोस्ट प्रिविलेज हो
गया। एंड सबसे बाहर वाला रिंग थ्री लिस्ट
प्रिविलेज्ड हो गया। ठीक है? ये पूरी की
पूरी चीज़ है जो आपको समझनी है। बस यही चीज़
मुझे समझानी थी। हम आगे फिर अभी बढ़ेंगे।
अब देखो जो कर्नल मोड होता है उसमें कुछ
अलग तरह की सर्विज ऑपरेट होती हैं।
एग्जीक्यूटिव सर्विज उसको आप बोल सकते हैं
या एग्जीक्यूटिव ज़ोन बोल सकते हैं। जहां
पे आपका कर्नल ऑपरेट करता है। जहां पे
डिवाइस के ड्राइवर्स ऑपरेट करते हैं। जहां
पे हार्डवेयर एब्स्ट्रैक्शन लेयर एच एल
ऑपरेट करते हैं। ये सारी चीजें आपका कर्नल
मोड में ऑपरेट करता है। ठीक है? अब डिवाइस
ड्राइवर क्या होते हैं? कर्नल क्या होते
हैं? इनके बारे में अगर जानना हो तो आप
थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा। बेसिकली आपका
जो कर्नल है वही
रिस्पांसिबल होता है आपके पूरे ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के फंक्शनैलिटीज के लिए। कर्नल ही
आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के स्टार्ट होने के
लिए, बूट अप होने के लिए एंड उसकी
सिक्योरिटी के लिए भी रिस्पांसिबल होता
है। तो एवरीथिंग इज़ कर्नल। कर्नल पे ही
पूरा का पूरा सिस्टम चलता है आपका। आपका
Linux का भी आपको पता होगा Linux भी एक
तरह का कर्नल ही है एंड आपका Windows का
कर्नल भी उसी तरीके से ऑपरेट करता है। उसी
तरह से डिवाइस ड्राइवर्स जो आप हार्डवेयर
डिवाइसेस वगैरह यूज़ करते हैं उसके जो
ड्राइवर्स आप इंस्टॉल करते हैं ना आप
बोलते हैं ना ड्राइवर है, ड्राइवर है,
ड्राइवर है। राइट? अब यहां पे
जैसे मैं कंट्रोल पैनल ओपन करता हूं।
ठीक है? अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं ऑप्शन होता है ना यहां
पे आपको डिवाइस मैनेजर का। जब आप डिवाइस
मैनेजर पे जाते हैं इस ऑप्शन पे तो आपको
यहां पे सारे ड्राइवर्स आपको दिखेंगे।
आपके अलग-अलग हार्डवेयर डिवाइसेस दिखेंगे
और उसके ड्राइवर्स आपको यहां पे दिखेंगे।
जैसे अगर मेरा मान लो मेरा नेटवर्क
ड्राइवर है। मान लो मेरा नेटवर्क अपर है
ये वाला। अब इसमें मेरा ये Intel वायरलेस
AC 9560 160 मेगाHz का ये जो अप्टर है यूज़
हो रहा है। मैं इसको राइट क्लिक करूंगा तो
यहां पे आएगा अपडेट ड्राइवर। यानी इसके
ड्राइवर को अपडेट करना। प्रॉपर्टीज पे
जाऊंगा तो इसकी डिटेल्स वगैरह आएंगी। इसका
मैन्युफैक्चरर कौन है? वर्जन क्या है? ये
सारी चीज़। तो ये जो ड्राइवर्स हैं ये इस
ये पूरी ड्राइवर्स आपकी इसी इसी ज़ोन में
ऑपरेट करता है जिसको हम कर्नल मोड बोलते
हैं। एंड दे ऑपरेट हियर इन द रिंग ज़ीरो।
रिंग ज़ीरो। तो जितनी भी क्रिटिकल
फंक्शन फंक्शनल चीजें होती हैं, जितनी भी
सर्विज होती हैं वो सारी रिंग ज़ीरो में
ऑपरेट करती हैं। जिनको सबसे ज्यादा
प्रिविलेज चाहिए। क्योंकि अगर प्रिविलेज
इनको नहीं मिलेगा तो जैसे आप मान लो कि
डिवाइस ड्राइवर्स हैं। अब उनको प्रिविलेज
नहीं मिलेगा तो आपके डिवाइसेस ही काम नहीं
करेंगे। मान लो कि आपका नेटवर्क डिवाइस
नेटवर्क डिवाइस है। ठीक है? आपका जो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मान लो नेटवर्क इंटरफ़ेस कार्ड है वो एक
ड्राइवर के थ्रू ऑपरेट कर रहा है। अब उस
ड्राइवर को अगर पूरी आप प्रॉपर परमिशन
देके नहीं रखेंगे, परमिशन उसको नहीं
मिलेगी तो आप जब कंप्यूटर को स्टार्ट करते
हैं, आप जो Wi-Fi से कनेक्ट करते हैं,
ब्लूटूथ से कनेक्ट करते हैं, वो कैसे
होगा? इट कैन नॉट ऑपरेट नॉर्मली। राइट? तो
दे नीड टू ऑपरेट इन द रिंग ज़ीरो विद द हाई
प्रिविलजेस जो कि आपका कर्नल मोड होता है।
उसी तरीके से यूजर मोड जो होता है उसमें
जो डीएलएल्स वगैरह डायनेमिक लिंक
लाइब्रेरीज़ डीएलएल्स वगैरह होते हैं जैसे
और अदर थिंग्स जैसे कि लाइक यूजर
एप्लीकेशनेशंस हो गए आपके प्रोसेससेस जो
सर्विसेस के प्रोसेससेस हो गए वो हो गए।
एनवायरमेंटल सब सिस्टम्स वगैरह सब सिस्टम
एनवायरमेंट वगैरह हो गए वो सारी चीज़ों वो
सारी चीजें आपकी काम करती हैं आपके यूजर
मोड में जिनको लिस्ट जो है प्रिविलेज
चाहिए उसके साथ भी वो काम कर लेंगे अब
जैसे Microsoft Word है तो उसको लिस्ट
प्रिविलेज ही चाहिए उसके साथ भी ऑपरेट
करेगा वो या जो भी एप्लीकेशन सॉफ्टवेयर है
उसको लिस्ट प्रिविलेज के साथ ऑपरेट करेगा
उसको ज्यादा प्रिविलेज दे देंगे कभी कोई
अटैक हुआ आपके सिस्टम पे तो उसके थ्रू
वायरसेस मलवेस को फैला दिया जाएगा जैसे
वर्ड माइक्रोस के थ्रू वनेबिलिटी
एक्सप्लइट हुई थी उसके थ्रू क्या होता था
एक नॉर्मल अगर वर्ड माइक्रोस के थ्रू उस
वनेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट करके आपके सिस्टम
का एक्सेस लिया जा सकता था। तो इस तरह से
एक लिस्ट प्रिविलेज एप्लीकेशन के थ्रू
हाईएस्ट प्रिविलेज के तरफ जाके इसको हम
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन बोलते हैं। वो काम
किया जाता है। तो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन इज़
नथिंग बट टू एलिवेट योर एक्सेस फ्रॉम रिंग
थ्री टू रिंग ज़ीरो। आप यह भी बोल सकते हैं
रिंग थ्री सर्विसेस टू रिंग ज़ीरो
सर्विसेस। आप ऐसा भी ये प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन का एक डेफिनेशन भी है। टेक्निकल
डेफिनेशन आप इस तरीके से बोल सकते हैं कि
अगर हम अपनी प्रिविलेज को एस्केलेट करें
फ्रॉम रिंग ज़ीरो रिंग थ्री टू रिंग ज़ीरो
की तरफ तो वो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन का एक
पार्ट हो जाता है। तो ये कुछ इस तरीके से
आर्किटेक्चर आपके काम करते हैं। अब देखो
अब यहां पे मैं इस एग्जांपल को मैं क्यों
पहले हटा चुका था? अ क्योंकि ये थोड़ा
कॉम्प्लेक्स था। तो इसको थोड़ा समझाना
पड़ेगा। इसके लिए आपको बताना था पहले रिंग
ज़ीरो क्या होता है? रिंग थ्री क्या होता
है? ये सब चीज़। तो कुछ इस तरीके से
Windows की आर्किटेक्चर आपकी दिखती है।
ठीक है? सबसे पहले आपका कंप्यूटर हो गया।
मतलब जो हार्डवेयर है ऑब्वियसली बात है।
जैसे मेरा ये मशीन है। मेरा ये लैपटॉप है।
ये हार्डवेयर है। इस पे मैं ऑपरेट कर रहा
हूं। राइट? तो ये हार्डवेयर आपका हो जाता
है। हार्डवेयर के ऊपर आपका शुरू हो जाता
है कर्नल मोड। जो आपका कर्नल मोड है दैट
स्टार्ट्स। अब यह कर्नल मोड जो है ना यह
पूरा का पूरा आपका कर्नल मोड जो है ऑपरेट
हो रहा है। यहां से यहां तक का यह पूरा
कर्नल मोड ऑपरेट हो रहा है।
उसके बाद यहां से शुरू होता है आपका
यूजर मोड। यह पूरा आपका एरिया यूजर मोड का
हो गया। अब कर्नल मोड के अंदर में एचएल
हार्डवेयर एब्स्ट्रैक्शंस लेयर्स आते हैं।
अब इसमें मल्टीपल चीज़ जैसे कि कर्नल मोड
ड्राइवर्स होते हैं आपके माइक्रो कर्नल्स
होते हैं। माइक्रो कर्नल्स भी एक चीज है।
यहां पे उसके अंदर फिर एग्जीक्यूटिव
सर्विज के अंदर में आएंगे। तो
एग्जीक्यूटिव सर्विज में आपका बेसिकली आई
इनपुट आउटपुट मतलब देयर और एग्जीक्यूटिव
सर्विज एंड ऑब्जेक्ट मैनेजर्स ये दो चीजें
होती हैं। इसके बीच आपके बहुत सारे अदर
सर्विसेज जो हैं वो ऑपरेट कर रहे होते
हैं। ये कुछ इस तरीके के सर्विज होते हैं
जिसमें इनपुट आउटपुट मैनेजर आपका हो गया।
सिक्योरिटी रेफरेंस मॉनिटर जो एसआरएम होता
है ये विंडोज आर्किटेक्चर का ही पार्ट है।
सिक्योरिटी सिक्योरिटी रेफरेंस मॉनिटर जो
कि बेसिकली सिक्योरिटी इनफोर्स करने के
लिए रिस्पांसिबल होता है। तो ये आपका हो
गया यहां पे आईपीसी मैनेजर वर्चुअल मेमोरी
मैनेजर हो गया। जितने वर्चुअल मेमोरीज़
वगैरह हैं वो सब मैनेज करने के लिए
प्रोसेससेस को मैनेज करने के लिए यहां पे
पीएपी मैनेज मैनेजमेंट्स मैनेज करने के
लिए पावर मैनेजमेंट करने के लिए Windows
मैनेज मैनेजमेंट करने के लिए ग्राफिक्स
मैनेज तो ये सारी जो मैनेजमेंट वाली चीजें
जो ठेका है वो सारा जो है वो कर्नल मोड के
अंदर में आता है जो आपके सिस्टम के
सर्विसेस को मैनेज करने के लिए मोस्टली
यूज़ में आते हैं। यानी कि जितने भी ऐसी
सर्विज जो आपके सिस्टम के चलाने के लिए
आपके सिस्टम को रन करने के लिए जरूरत होती
है। सिस्टम को ऑपरेट करने के लिए जरूरत
होती है। वो सारी आपकी किस में काम करती
है? आपकी कर्नल मोड में काम करती है। सारे
आपके इस रिंग ज़ीरो वाले में ये सारा कौन
सा है भैया? ये
रिंग ज़ीरो। एंड ये आपका यूजर मोड कौन सा
है?
रिंग थ्री। ठीक है? वन टू नॉट यूज़्ड।
तो आपको दिमाग में बस ये रखना है बंग एन
एसओ सीएल वन। देखो इसमें बहुत डीप आपको
जाने की जरूरत नहीं है। इतनी कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं पड़ने वाली आपकी। L1 के
लिए बिल्कुल भी इतनी रिक्वायरमेंट आपको
नहीं पड़ेगी। हां, L2, L3 वगैरह के लिए
जाएंगे तो आपको डीप थोड़ा घुसना पड़ेगा।
आप आपको पढ़ना पड़ेगा। तो L1 के लिए आपको
बस इनके टर्म्स थोड़े बहुत आईडिया होने
चाहिए। ये स्ट्रक्चर कैसा होता है वो
थोड़ा बहुत आईडिया हो। दैट्स इट कि भैया
एक हार्डवेयर के ऊपर में आपका कर्नल मोड
है जो स्टार्ट होती है जहां एचएल आपका काम
होता है। कर्नल मोड ड्राइवर्स होते हैं।
फिर एग्जीक्यूटिव सर्विसेस ऑब्जेक्ट
मैनेजर के बीच बहुत सारी सर्विज होती हैं।
जैसे कि इनपुट आउटपुट मैनेजर हो गया,
एसआरएम वगैरह हो गया, प्रोसेस मैनेजर हो
गया आपका ग्राफिक्स मैनेजर हो गया या आपका
भाई वर्चुअल मेमोरी मैनेजर हो। ये सारे
काम करते हैं। ये सारे आपके कर्नल मोड में
काम करते हैं। उसके बाद आती है यूजर मोड
में। यूजर मोड में सिंपल सा है। दो तरह के
होते हैं। एक इंटीग्रल सब सिस्टम और एक
एनवायरमेंटल सब सिस्टम। अब इंटीग्रल सब
सिस्टम मतलब जो आपका इंटीग्रेशन इंटीग्रल
पार्ट है जो आपके ओएस का आपके कम आपके
Windows का इंटीग्रल पार्ट है उससे
रिलेटेड है। एनवायरमेंटल सब सिस्टम का
मतलब है कि बेसिकली एनवायरमेंट के
एनवायरमेंटल बेसिस पे जो भी ऑपरेट कर रहे
हैं प्रोसेससेस जैसे आप जैसे कई बार क्या
होता है कि कोई एक सॉफ्टवेयर को यूज़ करना
होता है आपको। ठीक है? आपको मान लो कोई
जावा आपने बॉबs वगैरह यूज़ किया हो बीइंग
एन एथिकल हैकिंग स्टूडेंट हो या ऐसे तो
बॉबsट में भी यूज़ करते हो तो आपको वहां पे
एक एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल सेटअप करना पड़ता
है। JDK jवा का पाथ सेटअप करना पड़ता है।
चलो बॉबs छोड़ो कोई भी ऐसी एप्लीकेशन जहां
पे JDK jवा डेवलपमेंट किट का यूज़ हो रहा
है तो उसको कई बार आपको सिस्टम पाथ में
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल के अंदर उसको सेट करना
पड़ता है। तब जाके वो पाथ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
को समझ में आती है। तो वो एक एनवायरमेंटल
सब सिस्टम के अंदर उसका पाथ सेट होता है
कि भैया इस पाथ पे ये जो चीज़ पड़ी हुई है।
इसकी बाइनरी पड़ी है या इसका बाइनरी
एग्जीक्यूशन करना है आपको और वहां पे जाके
आप इसको यूज़ करो। जब भी मैं बोलूं कि हां
इससे रिलेटेड सर्विज चालू करनी है तो उस
लोकेशन पे जाओ और उसको एग्जीक्यूट करो। उस
जावा की जेडीके को जो जावा डेवलपमेंट किट
है या जेआरई जो होता है वो एग्जीक्यूट
करो। तो उस तरह की चीजें जो होती हैं वो
सेटअप आप करते हैं। तो यूजर मोड में
इंटीग्रल सब सिस्टम और एनवायरमेंटल सब
सिस्टम दो तरह के सब सिस्टम्स होते हैं।
ऑपरेट होती है। अब इंटीग्रल सब सिस्टम में
बहुत सारी चीजें आती हैं। जैसे वर्क
स्टेशन सर्विज हो गई आपकी सर्वर सर्विज हो
गई, सिक्योरिटी वगैरह हो गया। ये सब इसमें
आता है। Windows 32, wind 32 सर्विज जो हो
गई आपका या फिर possix जो हो गया या आपका
ओs बाय 2 ये जो होती है सर्विसेस जो होती
हैं ये सारी आपकी किसमें काम करती है?
एनवायरमेंटल सब सिस्टम। तो मतलब बेसिकली
ये सारी चीजें जो है यूजर मोड के अंदर में
काम करती है। बस यूजर मोड में सिंपल सा
फंडा है कि इसको याद रखना है कि यूजर मोड
में काम। अब Vin 32 में Win32 के
एप्लीकेशनेशंस आ गए यहां पे। यहां पे
पोsक्स एप्लीकेशनेशंस आ गए। ये सारे
एप्लीकेशनेशंस वगैरह इसमें ऑपरेट करते
हैं। तो अपने को याद क्या रखना है? क्या
दिमाग में रखना है कि
विंडोज आर्किटेक्चर के अंदर में
प्रोटेक्शन रिंग्स के बारे में हम बात
करते हैं। दिस जो हमने यहां पे देखा दीज़
आर कॉल्ड दीज़ आर कॉल्ड पी आर
पी आर प्रोटेक्शन रिंग्स। प्रोटेक्शन
रिंग्स के बारे में बात करें करते हैं
विंडोज़ के अंदर में। एंड प्रोटेक्शन
रिंग्स में दो मोड होते हैं। यूजर मोड एंड
कर्नल मोड। यूजर मोड जो है आउटर मोस्ट
स्लेयर होता है जो कि आपका रिंग थ्री में
ऑपरेट करता है। रिंग वन टू नॉट यूज्ड होता
है। एंड रिंग ज़ीरो में कर्नल मोड ऑपरेट
करता है जो आपका कर्नल जो सबसे ज्यादा
प्रिविलेज के साथ होता है। हां अब कर्नल
मोड के अंदर में कुछ सर्विज हैं। कुछ
चीजें हैं। आप इसमें से कुछ-कुछ याद कर
लीजिएगा अगर याद करना हो तो इंटरव्यू
पर्पस से यू कैन रिमेंबर मेमोराइज़ इट। एंड
यूजर मोड में जो सर्विज है उसको
हल्का-फुल्का मेमोराइज़। इससे ज्यादा आपको
नहीं जाना। इससे ज्यादा आपको जानने की
जरूरत एसओसी एल1 के लिए बिल्कुल भी नहीं
है। हां, आप वैसे अपनी नॉलेज को एनहांस
करने के लिए, इंक्रीस करने के लिए आप कुछ
भी पढ़ लीजिए, कुछ भी एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिए।
दैट वुड बी परफेक्टली फाइन। मैं हमेशा
बोलता हूं कि लर्निंग की एंड सीखने की कोई
लिमिटेशन नहीं होती है। आप कुछ भी लेकिन
एक स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में सीखेंगे, तो आपके
लिए वो यूज़फुल रहेगा। बाद में आपस्ट कुछ
में भी कीजिए, किसी भी चीज से कीजिए। डजंट
मैटर। ठीक है? यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा।
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? आर यू गेटिंग? आर यू
अंडरस्टैंडिंग द यूजर मोड, कर्नल मोड एंड
क्या एक्सैक्टली होते क्या है ये प्रोडक्ट
अर्निंग?
आर यू आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग
सभी लोग बता दीजिए एक बार प्लीज लेट मी नो
एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो फास्ट
एडी की सेशन में सिखाएंगे। एडी की सेशन की
एडी मतलब कौन सी एडी की सेशन? एडी की कौन
सी सेशन है भाई? गॉट इट गॉट इट गॉट इट गॉट
इट
यह कौन है भाई इंटेलिजेंटली
1 लाख है तो मैं क्या करूं भाई तुम्हारी
सैलरी कुछ भी हो उससे मुझे क्या है
सैलरी कुछ भी हो तभी भी भिखारियों की तरह
आ रहे हो यहां पे फिर क्या कर सकते हैं
समझ नहीं आया यार पता नहीं यार कहां से
कहां से लोग आ जाते हैं
हां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वही तो होंगे थोड़े बेगा टाइप लोग होते हैं
बेचारे आ जाते हैं उठ के।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके सो गाइज़ सभी के रिस्पांस नहीं आ रहे
हैं। थोड़े कम लोगों के रिस्पांस आए हैं।
सो प्लीज जो रिमेनिंग बाकी लोग देख रहे
हैं प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइज़। लेट मी नो।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
मैं ब्रीफ में एक बार ब्रीफिंग कर देता
हूं। मैं एक बार वो कर देता हूं। फटाफट
एक बार फटाफट ब्रीफ कर देता हूं। सिंपल
मैंने जो चीज आपको बताई
बस हां क्लियर है। बहुत लोगों का क्लियर
है। बट स्टिल
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या बट स्टिल आई आई आई एम आई एम गोइंग टू
रिपीट वंस मोर एक ब्रीफ में। सिंपल सा है।
विंड विंडोज आर्किटेक्चर के अंदर में हम
प्रोटेक्शन रिंग्स के बारे में बात करते
हैं। प्रोटेक्शन प्रोटेक्शन रिंग्स कुछ
रिंग ऐसे रिंग की तरह का एक स्ट्रक्चर
होता है। इसलिए प्रोटेक्शन रिंग इनको रिंग
बोलते हैं। क्योंकि आपके विंडोज के
सिक्योरिटी और इन सब की बात है।
प्रोटेक्शन की बात है। तो यहां पे
प्रोटेक्शन रिंग बोलते हैं। अब इस
प्रोटेक्शन रिंग में यहां पे ज़ीरो से लेके
थ्री तक रिंग होती हैं। रिंग ज़ीरो, रिंग
वन, रिंग टू, रिंग थ्री ऐसे होती है। रिंग
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ज़ीरो जो है
वह सबसे ज्यादा प्रिविलेज रिंग होता है
जिसको हम कर्नल मोड बोलते हैं। रिंग थ्री
जो होता है वो यूजर मोड कहलाता है जो कि
सबसे आउटर मोस्ट रिंग होता है जो कि सबसे
लीस्ट प्रिविलेज होता है। उसकी सबसे कम
प्रिविलेज होती है। सबसे कम पावर उसी के
पास होती है। और रिंग ज़ीरो के पास सबसे
ज्यादा पावर होता है। सबसे ज्यादा पावरफुल
होता है जहां पे कर्नल ऑपरेट करता है। और
रिंग थ्री में यूजर ऑपरेट करते हैं। यूजर
रिलेटेड सर्विसेस ऑपरेट करते हैं और रिंग
ज़ीरो में कर्नल रिलेटेड ऑपरेट करते हैं
सर्विसेस। तो कर्नल रिलेटेड सर्विज जो
सबसे ज्यादा प्रिविलेज होते हैं तो सबसे
ज्यादा पावरफुल होते हैं। वहां पे आपके
ड्राइवर्स डिवाइस के ड्राइवर्स वगैरह जो
होते हैं वो होते हैं। कर्नल आपका खुद
ऑपरेट करता है। चेल वगैरह होते हैं ये सब
चीजें। रिंग थ्री में जो लिस्ट प्रिविलज
होते हैं जैसे यूजर एप्लीकेशनेशंस हो गए,
सिस्टम सर्विसेस हो गए। ये सारी चीजें जो
हैं प्रोसेससेस जो हो गए वो सारे ऑपरेट
करते हैं। तो ये एक पूरा का पूरा एक
स्ट्रक्चर था जो कि मैंने यहां पे एक
डिटेल्ड स्ट्रक्चर के थ्रू भी आपको बताया
था। जहां पे मैंने आपको यहां पे बताया था
कि एक हार्डवेयर है। हार्डवेयर के ऊपर ही
सब कुछ होता है। लाइक जैसे आपका सिस्टम
है, आपका लैपटॉप है। इस तरीके से। राइट?
तो अब ये जो हार्डवेयर है, अब ये
हार्डवेयर के ऊपर कर्नल मोड आपका हो गया।
यूजर मोड आपका हो गया। ये सारी चीजें होती
हैं। राइट? तो आपका हार्डवेयर जैसे कर्नल
मोड हो गया। कर्नल मोड में वही रिंग थ्री
अह रिंग ज़ीरो वाला उसमें सारी चीजें ये
सारी आ गई और यूजर मोड में ये सारी चीजें
आपकी रिंग थ्री वाली आ गई। रिंग वन रिंग
टू आपके काम का नहीं होता है। तो ये पूरा
का पूरा एक स्ट्रक्चर होता है Windows के
अंदर। आई होप यू आर अंडरस्टैंडिंग राइट
समझ गए समझ रहे हैं आप आर यू नाउ यू गॉट
बता दीजिए एक बार बताइए जल्दी फटाफट बताइए
फटाफट बताइए
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस फास्ट
गॉट इट
ओके ग्रेट चलिए चलिए काफी लोगों को समझ
में अब आ चुका है नाउ वी विल
चलिए ठीक है बहुत बढ़िया अच्छी अच्छा लगा
ऐसे ही आप लोग रिप्लाई करो रिसोंड तो करो
एटलीस्ट जब मैं बोलता हूं तो रिसोंड तो
करो एटलीस्ट तो मजा आएगा ना ठीक है ओके
लेट्स गो टू द नेक्स्ट पार्ट ये आपका मोड
वाला और ये वाला समझ में आ गया अब यहां पे
थोड़ा सा इसी को हम डिटेल में समझते हैं
सो दैट योर कंफ्यूजन या जो भी चीजें हैं
वो क्लियर हो जाए और भी और भी ज्यादा
क्लेरिटी के साथ आ जाए। सबसे पहले हम यहां
पे यूजर मोड के बारे में बात करेंगे। देन
हम कर्नल मोड के बारे में बात करेंगे। ठीक
है सर क्या बेसिक्स बेसिक्स ही आना चाहिए
ये सब? हां देखो एसओसी अच्छा क्वेश्चन है।
मैं इसका आंसर कर देता हूं।
मैं एक बार एक बार यहां पे आंसर कर देता
हूं आपको। देखो द थिंग इज कि एसओसी एल1
आपका प्रोफाइल जो हो रहेगा ना जो एल1
प्रोफाइल के लिए जब आप जाएंगे तो एक
एंट्री लेवल जॉब होती है एंड वहां पे आपको
बेसिक्स बेसिक्स चीजें ही जाननी है एंड
साथ में अलर्ट ट्रैगिंग और जो एसआईएम और
ये सब चीजें वो आपको जानकारी चाहिए बस
दैट्स इट यू आर रेडी फॉर एस1 एल1 प्रोफाइल
बस उसी के अकॉर्डिंग आपको हम यहां पे करा
रहे हैं ठीक है
ठीक है। गॉट इट। आर यू गेटिंग?
कौन है भाई? डॉग्स आर बार्किंग बिहाइंड
यू। हां हां हां हां वो तो होता ही है।
डॉग्स आर बार्किंग।
कोई है यहां पे इंटेलिजेंट डीएस डी3 एस
करके। भाई रियल नेम से आओ। क्यों? ऐसे
फर्जीियों की तरह आ रहे हो। देखो अब चैट
में क्या होता है? में कोई आते हैं फेक
आईडी वगैरह बना के आते हैं और कुछ भी
फालतू लिख देते हैं। आई डोंट नो हु आर दे
कौन होते हैं ये लोग। पता नहीं मुझे समझ
नहीं आता क्योंकि उनकी बैंड इसलिए बच जाती
है क्योंकि यहां पे फ्री में क्लासे चल
रही हैं। फ्री में इस लेवल की क्लासेस चल
रही हैं। उनकी दुकानें बंद हो जाती है
बेचारों की। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आते हैं
फालतू बातें करते हैं। अब रियल आईडी से
रियल नेम से अपना नेम और नंबर नहीं बता
सकते वो। क्योंकि एक्चुअली में अगर रियल
नेम और नंबर वो बताएंगे तो उनका तो बैंड
बज जाएगा। मतलब मैं तो लाइव यहां पर बता
रहा हूं कि अगर यहां पर जो भी
फालतू बातें करते हैं अगर वह रियल नेम और
नंबर बता दे तो 2 मिनट लगेंगे मुझे उनकी
बैंड बजवाने में 2 मिनट बस उससे ज्यादा
नहीं। तो अगर कोई ऐसा कुछ है जो जैसे कुछ
लोग होते हैं जो यहां पे अब्यूज करते हैं
आके आई नो कि क्या रीज़न क्या होता है?
रीज़न यह होता है सिंपल सा मैं आपको बता
देता हूं कि उनको किसी ना किसी तरह की
तकलीफ हो रहा हो गई रहती है हमारे कोर्सेस
से हमारी क्लासेस से। एक तो कोर्सेज हमारी
पेड होती है वो बहुत अफोर्डेबल आता है और
फ्री क्लासेस में हम पता नहीं क्या-क्या
चीजें आपको बता रहे हैं तो उनका दुकान बंद
हो जा रहा है लाइक एक तरह से दुकान बंद
होता है कई बार तो वो अपनी भाड़ास निकालने
आते हैं कोई यहां पे है कुछ भी अ कुछ भी
बोल रहा है ऐसे करके तो नहीं ब्लॉक मारने
से नहीं है ब्लॉक मारना मैं ब्लॉक करने से
क्या फायदा हुआ कोई फायदा नहीं है लेट इट
बी रहने दो देखो जैसे कुत्ता पीछे भौक रहा
था अभी किसी ने बोला कि सर आपके पीछे डॉग
भौक रहा है तो ऐसे ही तो बहुत सारे होते
हैं यार डॉग्स डॉग्स का काम है भौकना।
कुत्ते का काम क्या होता है? भौंकना। अब
आप उस पे रिएक्ट करोगे जाके तब उस कुत्ते
को मारने जाओगे तो कुत्ता काटेगा नहीं।
भौकने तो नहीं यार डॉगीज़ का काम होता है
भौकना। बैकग्राउंड में भौके या कहीं और
भौके। लेट इट बी। राइट? लेट इट बी।
रुद्र मराठे आपने यहां पे बहुत स्पैम किया
है। तो आपको यहां पे हम टाइम आउट कर रहे
हैं 1 मिनट के लिए। सो दैट आप यहां पे
स्पैम ना करें। स्पैमिंग स्पैम ना करना
सबके लिए वैलिड है। कोई भी स्पैम करेगा तो
उसको टाइम आउट करना ही है। तो प्लीज डोंट
स्पैम राइट हां राइट राइट राइट राइट
हां वही बात है। नहीं उन लोगों के लिए
मैंने बोला कि कुत्ते तो बैकग्राउंड में
भौकते रहते हैं। उनका क्या करोगे? कुत्तों
को बैकग्राउंड में भौंकने दो। अपना काम
करो। डॉगीज कीप ऑन बार्किंग एंड लेट्स यू
लेट्स डू योर वर्क। दैट्स इट। उनकी अपने
आप भौंकना शांत हो जाएगा। देखो जैसे
भौंकना रुक गया अभी। अभी एक यहां का
कुत्ता भौंकना रुक गया। है ना? तो जब
इग्नोर आप कर दोगे ना तो बाकी जितने भी
कुत्ते भौंक रहे होते हैं वो सब अपने आप
शांत हो। भौकते-भौकते बेचारे दुख जाएगा
ना। मुंह दुख जाएगा बेचारों के। क्या कर
सकते हैं? लेकिन अपना रियल नेम और नंबर
अगर कोई दे दे तो मालूम मैं रियल नेम और
नंबर दो। तो फिर मैं बताता हूं। फिर तो
एक्चुअल में कुत्ता बनाना पड़ेगा। ऐसे
लोगों को 2 मिनट का काम है बनाना।
हां। रूट किट्स क्या होते हैं भैया? देखो
रूट किट क्या होता है? रूट किट्स जो होते
हैं ना वो कर्नल लेवल पे कर्नल लेवल पे ही
ऑपरेट करते हैं। रिंग ज़ीरो में जाके ऑपरेट
करते हैं। ये एक तरह के ऐसे मैल्वस बोल
सकते हो। मैल्वस होते हैं जो आपके कर्नल
लेवल तक के आपके कंप्यूटर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज
कर लेते हैं। कंप्लीट आपके कंप्यूटर को
कंप्लीटली कंप्रोमाइज कर लेंगे और आपके
कंप्यूटर में बैठ जाएंगे बैठ के। एंड
अलग-अलग तरह से परफॉर्मेंस करेंगे अपना
अकॉर्डिंग टू द C2 एंड रिजल्ट्स देंगे।
मतलब एक तरह का मैलवेरी आप उसको बोलो। ठीक
है?
चलिए अब यहां पे हम यूजर मोड में यूजर मोड
और कर्नल मोड को थोड़ा डिटेल में थोड़ा
मतलब वैसे समझते हैं। तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यूजर मोड रंस
क्या? एप्लीकेशनेशंस जैसे Chrome, वर्ड ये
सब एप्लीकेशन रन करते हैं। यूजर के
प्रोसेससेस रन करता है एंड सम यूजर
सर्विज, यूजर रिलेटेड सर्विसेस ये सब
चीजें रन करते हैं। ये यूजर मोड होते हैं
आपके। ठीक है? यूजर मोड में। रेस्ट्रिकशंस
इसमें क्या है? व्हाट आर द रेस्ट्रिकशंस?
रेस्ट्रिकशंस में यहां पे है कैन नॉट
डायरेक्टली एक्सेस हार्डवेयर। कैन नॉट
मॉडिफाई कर्नल। डायरेक्टली ये हार्डवेयर
को एक्सेस नहीं कर सकते हैं। ठीक है?
सिंपल सा फंडा है। डायरेक्टली हार्डवेयर
को एक्सेस नहीं कर सकते हैं। एंड एंड
मॉडिफाई कर्नल को मॉडिफाई नहीं कर सकते
हैं। ये इनका कुछ रेस्ट्रिक्शन है आपका।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एसओसी
रेलेवेंस की अगर हम बात करें तो मोस्ट
मैलवेयर स्टार्ट्स हियर। एसोसिएट रे
11वेंस की अगर बात करें तो मोस्ट जो
मैलवेस है वो अह यूजर मोड से ही स्टार्ट
करते हैं। मैल्वेस अपने आपको इनफेक्ट करना
जो है कंप्यूटरटर्स को इनफेक्ट करना वो
स्टार्ट कहां से होती है? वो यूजर मोड से
होती है। जैसे कि मान लो कि कोई फिशिंग
अटैक हुआ। फिर वो उसमें वर्ड जो है वर्ड
के थ्रू पावर शेल के थ्रू एग्जीक्यूशन
करते हैं। एंड वहां पे अ जो भी मैलवेयर्स
होते हैं उसको प्लांट करते हैं। तो
नॉर्मली जैसे फिशिंग किया वर्ड का कोई
वलेबिलिटी है। माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड का कोई
वलेबिलिटी है माइक्रो रिलेटेड कोई उसका
एक्सप्लइट है। उसको उस एक्सप्लइट का यूज़
किया। फिर पावर सेल के थ्रू कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट किया और आपके पूरे सिस्टम पे
कॉम्प्रोमाइज। आपके पूरे सिस्टम को क्या
किया? कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया। दिस इज़ द
थिंग। दिस इज़ द यूजर मोड। यह यूजर मोड में
यह सारी चीज़ एसओसी के लिए रेलेवेंस की ये
चीज़ हैं। तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यूजर मोड का भी कॉम्प्रोमाइज होना इट्स
नॉट नॉर्मल थिंग। अगर यूजर मोड कोई किसी
ने कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया है, यूजर मोड में
आ गया है तो फिर वो कर्नल मोड तक पहुंच
सकता है। इट्स इजी फॉर देम। कर्नल मोड की
हम बात करें यहां पे तो रंस Windows कर्नल
को रन करता है। ड्राइवर्स वगैरह की सब कुछ
रनिंग वगैरह का यही देखता है हमारा। और
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मेमोरी
मैनेजर जो होते हैं वर्चुअल मेमोरी मैनेजर
वो सब काम कर्नल का ही होता है। कर्नल मोड
में ही होता है। पावर क्या होता है? फुल
सिस्टम एक्सेस होता है इसके पास। तो अगर
कर्नल मोड में कोई मैलवेयर ऑपरेट कर रहा
है तो उसके पास पूरे सिस्टम का एक्सेस
होता है। फुल सिस्टम एक्सेस। राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एसोसिएट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] रेवेंस
की हम यहां पे बात करें तो रूट किट्स
ऑपरेट हियर। रूट किट्स वगैरह जो है वो
यहीं पे ऑपरेट करते हैं जो अ
एक तरह के मैलवेरी ही होते हैं। रूट किट्स
अपने आप को हाइड करके रखते हैं।
लोकेशनेशंस पे एंड एकदम छिपा के अपने को
स्टिल्ट रखते हैं। सारा काम करते हैं।
कर्नल कॉम्प्रोमाइज इक्वल टू कंप्लीट
सिस्टम कंट्रोल। ठीक है? कर्नल अगर
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ तो पूरा का पूरा सिस्टम
जो है आपका कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाएगा। यह
पूरा कर्नल मोड होता है आपका। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे
यहां पे Windows कर्नल की हम बात करें।
जैसे कर्नल मोड में हम Windows कर्नल की
बात कर रहे हैं यहां पे। तो Windows कर्नल
क्या करता है? एग्जैक्टली कर्नल का काम
क्या है? जैसे कई बार हम हम कर्नल कर्नल
पढ़ रहे हैं। बट एग्जैक्टली कर्नल का काम
क्या होता है? व्हाट एग्जैक्टली कर्नल डू?
कर्नल का काम हैंडल्स सीपीयू शेड्यूलिंग
इंटरपशंस थ्रेड एग्जीकशंस तो जो भी सीपीू
की शेड्यूलिंग ओवर हो गई एग्जीक्यूशन हो
गया थ्रेड का हो गया ये सब सब कुछ जो है
कर्नल ही आपका जो है वो हैंडल करता है
मतलब पूरा का पूरा आपका सिस्टम जो है
कर्नल चलाता है एक तरह से आप यह समझ लीजिए
कि आपका जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम चल रहा है या
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ऑपरेट हो रहा है वो कर्नल
की मेहरबानी है कर्नल ही रीज़ है सब कुछ
एसओसी के इंसाइट के बारे में बात करें तो
रेयरली डायरेक्टली अटैक्ड बट इफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज स्टिल मैलवेयर तो ऐसे कर्नल
डायरेक्ट कर्नल कॉम्प्रोमाइज डायरेक्टली
जो है वो बहुत रेयर होता है। इट्स नॉट दैट
इजी। तो क्या होता है? पहले यूजर मोड के
थ्रू जो है अटैकर्स जो है वो मैलवेयर
प्लांट करते हैं। फिर वहां से एस्केलेट
करके कर्नल मोड तक पहुंचते हैं या कर्नल
तक पहुंचने की कोशिश करते हैं। डायरेक्ट
कर्नल एक्सप्लइट कर्नल इट्स नॉट दैट इजी।
तो ये Windows कर्नल की बात हो गई। अब आते
हैं यहां पे कुछ एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर्स।
जैसे मैंने यहां पे पहले हमने देखा था ना
ये एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर्स में जैसे कर्नल हो
गई आपकी डिवाइस ड्राइवर्स हो गया एचएल हो
गया ऐसे एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर्स की बात करते
हैं तो यहां पे एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर्स में
यहां पे दो तरह की चीजें होती है। जैसे
मैंने यहां पे भी दिखाया था आपको यहां पे
एग्जीक्यूटिव सर्विज जो दिखाई थी मैंने तो
इसमें दिखाया था आपको कि प्रोसेस मैनेजर
होते हैं, वर्चुअल मेमोरी मैनेजर होते
हैं, आईओ मैनेजर होता है, सिक्योरिटी
रेफरेंस मॉनिटर हो गया आपका, पावर मैनेजर
हो गया, Windows मैनेजर ये सब कुछ होते
हैं। तो यहां पे एग्जीक्यूटिव मैनेजर में
प्रोसेस मैनेजर की अगर हम बात करें जो कि
एक एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर के अंदर ही आता है।
ठीक है? सर रिकॉर्डिंग ही देखूंगा क्योंकि
आप क्वेश्चन क्वेश्चन
क्वेश्चन नहीं लेते हैं। ठीक है? आप
रिकॉर्डिंग देखो सचिन कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
आप क्वेश्चन अगर आपको लग रहा है कि नहीं
लेते हैं तो आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है। मुझे कोई इशू नहीं आ गया।
आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखो या कुछ भी देखो उसे
डजंट मैटर। ठीक है? क्वेश्चन यहां पे मैं
पढ़ा रहा हूं तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है कि मैं
यहां पे फोकस कर रहा हूं। आपके क्वेश्चन
पे फोकस बिल्कुल भी नहीं कर रहा। ठीक है?
तो आपकी मर्जी है वो। दैट्स टोटली योर
चॉइस। एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर की बात करें तो
यहां पे प्रोसेस मैनेजर की हम बात करते
हैं। ठीक है? प्रोसेस मैनेजर एंड मेमोरी
मैनेजर की हम बात करते हैं। प्रोसेस
मैनेजर का काम क्या होता है? प्रोसेससेस
को क्रिएट करना। जो भी आपके प्रोसेससेस
क्रिएट होते हैं। जैसे कि मैं यहां पे
आपको दिखाता हूं। चलो यहां पे मैं टास्क
मैनेजर स्टार्ट करते हैं हम। ठीक है? वी
आर स्टार्टिंग टास्क मैनेजर। अब ये टास्क
मैनेजर में आपको यहां पे दिख रहे होंगे।
प्रोसेससेस दिख रहे हैं। राइट? ये बैक ये
प्रोसेससेस अभी जो चल रहे हैं फोरग्राउंड
के। यह बैकग्राउंड के प्रोसेससेस आपके दिख
रहे हैं। बहुत सारे प्रोसेससेस होते हैं।
तो, यह प्रोसेससेस को क्रिएट करने का जो
काम होता है, वह आपका प्रोसेस मैनेजर करता
है। दैट वर्क इज़ बीइंग डन बाय द प्रोसेस
मैनेजर। एसओसी के लिए ये क्या रेलेवेंस
है? तो, डिटेक्ट एबनॉर्मल प्रोसेससेस
स्पॉनिंग। इसमें एसओसी क्या देखना चाहेगा
कि एसओसी की नजर किस चीज पे रहेगी? कि
एब्नॉर्मल प्रोसेससेस कोई ऐसा तो नहीं है
कोई एब्नॉर्मल प्रोसेससेस जो हैं वो
बार-बार क्रिएट हो रहे हैं, बार-बार चल
रहे हैं। कोई एब्नॉर्मल प्रोसेससेस
एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है। ये ध्यान रखना है
एज बीइंग एन एसओसी। मेमोरी मैनेजर की बात
करें तो ये मेमोरी एलोकेट करता है। अब हर
प्रोसेस को हर जो प्रोसेस है वो एक मेमोरी
के अंदर में काम करती है। जितने भी विंडोज़
में प्रोसेससेस चलते हैं वो एक मेमोरी
उसको असाइन होती है। उसी मेमोरी के अंदर
उसको काम करना है। उस मेमोरी से बाहर अगर
जाता है तो वो ओवरफ्लो होता है। जब कोई
प्रोसेस मेमोरी से बाहर ऑपरेट करने लगता
है। मेमोरी जितनी असाइंड है उससे बाहर
ऑपरेट करने लगता है। उसमें ओवरफ्लो होता
है। और उस ओवरफ्लो वर्ड से आपको कोई ऐसी
टर्मिनोलॉजी याद आ रही है ओवरफ्लो नाम से
जो कि बेसिकली एथिकल हैकिंग में पढ़ाया
जाता है। कई बार सिखाया जाता है। तो आप
बताइए गेस कीजिए। मैं चैट में देख रहा
हूं। ओवरफ्लो से आपको क्या याद आ रहा है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बताइए प्लीज
या
ओवरफ्लो से बफर ओवरफ्लो की याद आती है
हमें वी रिमेंबर द बफर ओवरफ्लो राइट
हम वी रिमेंबर द बफर ओवरफ्लो तो जब मेमोरी
से बाहर हर कोई प्रोसेस काम करने लगता है।
एडजेसेंट मेमोरी एडजेसेंट जो आपकी
प्रोसेससेस है उसके थ्रू उससे कोलीजन होती
है तो बफर ओवरफ्लो नाम की बीमारी पैदा
होती है। एंड यह एक बफर ओवरफ्लो जो है वह
एक तरह का हमारे एथिकल है में डीडीओएस
अटैक का पार्ट है आपका मतलब कि लाइक सॉरी
डॉस अटैक का पार्ट है कि बफर ओवरफ्लो
कराना एंड एंड बेसिकली बफर ओवरफ्लो एक तरह
का डोस डिनाइयल ऑफ़ सर्विसेस का एक पार्ट
है कि जिसके थ्रू एक एडजेसेंट मेमोरी एक
एडजेसेंट प्रोसेस के साथ एक प्रोसेस का जो
मेमोरी से बाहर आके काम करना और उससे
टकराना एंड
देन बफर और फ्लो होता है जिसके कारण कई
बार जो है आपकी
कभी कोई डिवाइसेस जो है वो फेल कर जाएंगे।
ड्राइवर्स कोई सही से ऑपरेट नहीं करेंगे।
कोई डिवाइस सही से ऑपरेट नहीं करेगी। आपका
विंडो सही से कई बार काम नहीं करेगा। ब्लू
स्क्रीन ऑफ़ डेथ कई बार आप लोगों ने देखा
होगा। सो देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट दैट
आर द आउटकम्स ऑफ़ दिस काइंड ऑफ़ अटैक्स जो
डॉस्ट अटैक बफर फ्लो कैटेगरी में आते हैं।
तो ये वही चीज़ है मेमोरी मैनेजर में
मेमोरी को एलोकेट किया जाता है। एज अ
एसओसी आपके पास क्या होनी चाहिए आपके
दिमाग में कि फाइललेस मालवेयर लिव्स हियर
मतलब कि ऐसी मैल्वेस बेसिकली जो मतलब अ
यहां पे अह मेमोरी अगर एलोकेट हो रही है
तो मान लो कि उस मेमोरी के अंदर में कोई
मैलवेयर आके सीट कर जा रहा है। मैवेयर
बैठा हुआ है एंड मेमोरी लेवल तक की करप्शन
मेमोरी लेवल तक की अटैक कर रहा है। सो दिस
इज़ अ वेरी ह्यूज़ थिंग नॉट ईजी नॉट दैट ईजी
बट स्टिल दैट्स अ वेरी ह्यूज़ थिंग। राइट?
तो ये आपका क्या होते हैं? ये आपके होते
हैं एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर में प्रोसेस मैनेजर
एंड मेमोरी मैनेजर। प्रोसेस मैनेजर का काम
है प्रोसेससेस क्रिएट करना। मेमोरी मैनेजर
का काम है मेमोरीज़ जो एलोकेट करना होता
है। मेमोरी जो हर प्रोसेससेस को मेमोरी को
एलोकेट करना। अब एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर में और
होते हैं। आईओ मैनेजर भी होता है और
एसआरएम भी होता है। तो आईओ मैनेजर क्या
करता है? ये हैंडल्स डिस्क प्लस नेटवर्क।
तो जितने भी डिस्क रिलेटेड काम है आपके
कोई भी डिस्क रिलेटेड काम आपका हो गया
जैसे आपका हार्ड डिस्क हो गया, एसएसडी हो
गया, जो भी डिस्क रिलेटेड काम है या
नेटवर्क रिलेटेड काम है वो सब आपका इनपुट
आउटपुट मैनेजर काम करता है। ठीक है? इसमें
एसओसी के लिए क्या है? डिटेक्ट एबनॉर्मल
फाइल या नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी। अगर कोई फाइल
एक्टिविटी या नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी एबनॉर्मल
हो रहा है कुछ अलग टाइप से हो रहा है तो
वो जो है उसके डिटेक्शन के लिए एसओसी होते
हैं। उसको डिटेक्ट करना पड़ेगा। डिटेक्ट
करना चाहिए बीइंग एन एसओसी। सिक्योरिटी
रेफरेंस मॉनिटर एसआरएम एक होती है जिसमें
क्या होता है? कोर सिक्योरिटी इंजन चेकक्स
कैन दिस यूजर एक्सेस दिस ऑब्जेक्ट। यह
यूजर की जो यूजर होती है उसकी प्रिविलेज
का सारा बड़ा जो है यही रखता है जो आपका
सिक्योरिटी रेफरेंस मॉनिटर और सिक्योरिटी
को इनफोर्स करता है। तो बेसिकली ये बता ये
ये देखता है कि क्या इस यूजर को ये चीज़
एक्सेस करनी चाहिए? ये चीज़ एक्सेसबल इस
यूजर को होनी चाहिए। इस यूजर को ये चीज़
अवेलेबल होनी चाहिए। तो यहां पे क्या हो
रहा है? अवेलेबिलिटी चेक हो रही है यूजर
की अवेले अब ये पर्टिकुलर चीज ये
पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेस ये पर्टिकुलर सर्विस
क्या इस यूजर के द्वारा एक्सेस होनी चाहिए
क्या इस यूजर को अवेलेबल होना चाहिए तो ये
प्रिविलेज चेक करता है देखता है कि भैया
ये यूजर इसको एक्सेस कर सकता है कि नहीं
कर सकता सिक्योरिटी इनफोर्समेंट का सारा
काम एसआरएम का होता है इसलिए नाम भी
सिक्योरिटी सिक्योरिटी रेफरेंस मॉनिटर ठीक
है एसआरएम तो ये कुछ एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर्स
थे जिसमें कि हमने प्रोसेस मैनेजर मेमोरी
मैनेजर आईओ मैनेजर सिक्योरिटी रेफरेंस
मॉनिटर ऐसे बहुत सारे एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर्स
जो एग्जीक्यूटिव यहां पे लेयर्स होते हैं।
बहुत सारे होते हैं। मैं आपसे एक एज अ
टास्क मैं आपसे यही बोलूंगा कि आप
एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर्स जो होते हैं उसके
बारे में थोड़ा सा एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा।
थोड़ा सा पढ़िएगा। लाइक लाइक गो ऑन एंड
रीड इट। थोड़ा बहुत आईडिया मिल जाएगा।
थोड़ा नॉलेज मिल जाएगा। राइट? दैट्स इट।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आई होप कि समझ में आ रहा होगा।
बहुत आपको यह समझ में आ रहा होगा। एसओसी
यूज़ केस में क्या है कि प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशंस अनअथराइज्ड एक्सेस यह सारी
चीजें जो है इनके थ्रू होती है। प्रिविलज
एस्केलेशंस अगर हो रही हैं तो ऑब्वियस सी
बात है इसके थ्रू हो रही है। ऑथराइज्ड
एक्सेस जो है हो रहा है वो इसके थ्रू हो
रहा है। एसआरएम वगैरह बाईपास हो रहा है।
ये सारी चीजें हो रही है। सो या समझ में
आया? ठीक है? अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे एक
और समझते हैं हम यहां पे। जैसा मैंने आपको
यहां बताया था इमेज में कि एक हार्डवेयर
एब्स्ट्रैक्शन लेयर होता है एच एल हम
फिलहाल उसी की उसी के बारे में बात करने
वाले हैं एंड ड्राइवर्स के बारे में
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एचएल होता है हार्डवेयर एब्स्ट्रैक्शन
लेयर क्या होता है ये इंटरफेस होता है
बिटवीन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एंड हार्डवेयर जो
आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है और हार्डवेयर
होता है उसके बीच का यह इंटरफ़ेस है कि भाई
कनेक्शन है तो आपका हार्डवेयर जो है उसको
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से कनेक्ट करता है आपका
एच एल हार्डवेयर एब्स्ट्रैक्शन लेयर दैट्स
इट सिंपल कोई भी पूछे कि भैया हार्डवेयर
हार्डवेयर जो हमारा है कंप्यूटर एंड जो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हमने इंस्टॉल करा उसके
बीच का जो कनेक्शन है बनाने वाला काम करता
है वो हमारा एचएल ही करता है दैट्स इट
हार्डवेयर एब्स्ट्रैक्शन लेयर एसओसी के
लिए क्या है यूज्ड इन एडवांस्ड रूट किट्स
ठीक है मतलब एडवांस रूट किट्स जो होते हैं
वो इसको एक्सप्लइट करने की कोशिश करते हैं
वो जो हार्डवेयर और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
बीच के कनेक्शन है उसको एक्सप्लइट करने की
कोशिश करते हैं कंट्रोल करने की कोशिश
सी्स करते हैं कि जैसे कोई सर्विसेस के
थ्रू, कोई प्रोसेससेस के थ्रू आपके
हार्डवेयर में इशू कर देना। सोचो दैट लेवल
ऑफ़ थिंग आप लोगों ने
आप लोगों ने वो चीज देखी है वो मूवी डाई
हार्ड 4.0 किसी ने देखी है?
हाउ मेनी ऑफ़ यू हैव सीन डाई हार्ड 4.0 ये
एक मूवी है हॉलीवुड की डाई हार्ड 4.0
लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू हैव सीन।
बताइए
नहीं देखा आप लोगों ने ओके मैं आप सबसे एक
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सबसे बोलूंगा आप लोग जो है इस मूवी को
देखिएगा।
डाय हार्ड 4.
यह मूवी है डायardड 4 लिव फ्री और डाई
हार्ड। ठीक है? दिस इज़ द मूवी लिव फ्री और
डाई हार्ड। वैसे इसका नाम है लिव फ्री और
डाई हार्ड बट डाई हार्ड को थोड़ा ज्यादा वो
करते हैं। यह आपको Jio Hotstar पे मिल
जाएगी। आपको प्राइम वीडियो पे मिल जाएगी।
इन सब पे मिल जाएगी। तो, आप इसको देखिएगा।
राइट? इसको श्योरली देखिएगा। यह दिस इज़ वन
ऑफ़ द ग्रेट मूवी हैकिंग के ऊपर है थोड़ा सा
आपको। आपको लेकिन मजा आएगा। ऐसा भी नहीं
है कि बहुत बोर लगेगा। बहुत मजा आएगा आपको
यह मूवी देख के। ठीक है?
इसमें आपको देखने को मिलेगा कि कैसे एक
हैकर ने एक सर्विसेस एक मैलवेयर के थ्रू
उसका यूज़ करके सामने वाले बंदे का पूरा
सीपीू ब्लास्ट कर देता है। सीपीयू
हार्डवेयर को कंट्रोल। तो यही चीज़ यहां पे
है। HL को कंट्रोल करना। एडवांस रूट किट्स
में यूज़ होते हैं जिससे सर्विज या
प्रोसेससेस के थ्रू आप किसी के हार्डवेयर
डिवाइस पे इंपैक्ट डाल सकते हैं। तो इसमें
वही चीज मूवी में आपको देखने को मिल जाएगी
कि एक मैलवेयर के थ्रू किस तरीके से
डिवाइस जो है उसको इतना हीट कर दिया जा
रहा है कि वो पूरा का पूरा ब्लास्ट कर जा
रहा है। मतलब वो इलेक्ट्रिक
अ कुछ डिस्टरबेंसेस हो रहे हैं करंट्स में
एंड दे हीट अप एंड ब्लास्ट। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वलेबिलिटी रिस्क और थ्रेट में क्या
डिफरेंस है? ये मैंने ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ
है।
ओके। अब यहां पे डिवाइस ड्राइवर्स की बात
करते हैं यहां पे। तो डिवाइस ड्राइवर्स
क्या होते हैं? कम्युनिकेट विद द
हार्डवेयर। अब जो ड्राइवर्स का काम होता
है वो काम होता है हार्डवेयर से
कम्युनिकेट करना। दैट्स इट। जो भी
हार्डवेयर है उससे कम्युनिकेट करना। अब
जैसे मेरा नेटवर्क इंटरफ़ेस कार्ड है। मेरा
हार्डवेयर है उससे उसका ड्राइवर उससे
कम्युनिकेट करेगा। अब मेरा मान लो जैसे
वाई-फाई है तो उसका जो ड्राइवर है उससे
कम्युनिकेट कर रहा है। ब्लूटूथ वाला उस
वायरलेस जो ड्राइवर है उससे कम्युनिकेट कर
रहा है। आपका कीबोर्ड है उसका जो ड्राइवर
है उसके थ्रू कम्युनिकेट करता है। तो ये
कम्युनिकेशन का काम करते हैं ड्राइवर्स।
ड्राइवर्स जो है वो सीधा-सीधा हार्डवेयर
से कम्युनिकेट करते हैं। ठीक है? थ्रेट की
अगर हम बात करें तो क्या है? वनरेबल
ड्राइवर्स अगर हैं कोई तो प्रिविलज्लेशन
हो सकती है वहां से। ठीक है? साइन ड्राइवर
यूज़। ड्राइवर्स को एक रॉन्ग सिग्नेचर के
साथ साइन करके उसको ऑथेंटिक बनाने की
कोशिश करना है ना एंड फिर उसके थ्रू
एक्सप्लइट करना ये चीजें होती है। बेसिकली
अगर कोई ड्राइवर है वो वनरेबल है। ड्राइवर
अगर वनरेबल है सिंपल ड्राइवर एक तरह का
सॉफ्टवेयर हो गया। वो वनेरेबल है तो उसके
थ्रू जो है वो सिस्टम में घुसा जा सकता
है। हार्डवेयर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया जा
सकता है। हार्डवेयर में अलग-अलग तरह की
चीजें की जा सकती है। प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
किया जा सकता है कि एक नॉर्मल यूजर के
थ्रू एक ज्यादा प्रिविलज यूजर या
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव यूजर के तरफ बढ़ा जा सकता
है। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड जो थ्रेट ड्राइवर्स के
थ्रू आ सकते हैं। यह बीइंग एन एसओसी आपको
पता होना चाहिए। दैट्स इट। या
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
राइट के थ्रू
रै के थ्रू भी होती है। करेक्ट।
अब यहां पर Windows प्रोसेस आर्किटेक्चर
के बारे में हम जानते हैं। अभी तक हमने
Windows आर्किटेक्चर नॉर्मली देखा था। अब
हम यहां पे थोड़ा जानते हैं Windows
प्रोसेस आर्किटेक्चर क्या होती है? राइट?
अ Windows प्रोसेस इज़ एन एग्जीक्यूटिंग
इंस्टेंस ऑफ अ प्रोग्राम। ठीक है? एक्टिंग
एज अ कंटेनर फॉर रिसोर्सेज लाइक मेमोरी
हैंडल्स एंड थ्रेड्स नीडेड टू रन
एप्लीकेशनेशंस।
ठीक है? अब यहां पर सिंपल सा Windows
प्रोसेस क्या है? प्रोसेस एक
एग्जीक्यूटिंग इंस्टेंस ऑफ प्रोग्राम है।
या आपने पहले भी पढ़ा होगा कि एक
एग्जीक्यूटिंग इंस्टेंस जो होता है
प्रोग्राम का वो प्रोसेस होता है। ठीक है?
प्रोसेस यानी प्रोग्राम का एक सबसे बहुत
छोटा सा वो होता है जो कि एक प्रोग्राम
एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है। आप किसी प्रोग्राम
को डबल क्लिक करके चलाते हैं लाइक कोई भी
कोई भी सॉफ्टवेयर कोई भी अ लाइक कोई भी
तरह का प्रोग्राम होता है आप सॉफ्टवेयर
होता है उसको जब आप एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं
तो वो जो एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है उस टाइम
में उसकी प्रोसेससेस चलनी शुरू हो जाती
है। हर सॉफ्टवेयर जैसे कि मैं यहां पे
आपको दिखा देता हूं। अ टास्क मैनेजर
देखिए अब यहां पे है। अब मान लो Chrome
मेरा चल रहा है तो Chrome का एक यहां पे
प्रोसेस चल रहा है। आप देख सकते हैं इतने
सारे प्रोसेससेस चल रहे हैं। Chrome एक
एप्लीकेशन है। Chrome इज़ एन एप्लीकेशन
राइट? अब उसके बहुत सारे प्रोसेससेस चल
रहे हैं। ओबीएस चल रही है। ओबीएस के बहुत
सारे प्रोसेससेस चल रहे हैं। उसी तरीके से
नीचे की तरफ आएंगे। तो यहां पे आप देखेंगे
हर चीज़ की प्रोसेससेस चलेंगे। जैसे मैं
यहां पे आपको देखो जीpu जीpu का Intel
जो आपका Intel का खुद का एक डिफॉल्ट जीpu
ग्राफिक्स होता है वो आपका यहां पे चल रहा
है यहां पे Java का चल रहा है यहां पे
Microsoft Office का यहां पे चल रहा है।
देन NVDA का यहां पे चल रहा है यहां पे
ओपन VPN का चल रहा है। तो जो जो सर्विज
यहां पे मैं प्रोग्राम्स यूज़ कर रहा हूं
जनरली उन सबके प्रोसेससेस बैकग्राउंड में
आपके चल रहे होते हैं। तो हम बेसिकली
उन्हीं को प्रोसेस बोलते हैं। एंड उसी हम
प्रोसेस की यहां पे फिलहाल बात कर रहे
हैं। ठीक है? तो ये एक तरह से एक कंटेनर
होते हैं। लाइक अलग-अलग रिसोर्सेज जैसे
मेमोरी हो गई उसके कंटेनर हैं। ये उसको
कंटेन करने का काम करते हैं। एप्लीकेशन को
रन करने के लिए सबसे ज्यादा यूज़ होते हैं।
यूज़फुल होते हैं। क्योंकि बिना प्रोसेससेस
के कोई भी एप्लीकेशन रन नहीं होती है। इट
इज़ अ [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
फंडामेंटल यूनिट मैनेज्ड बाय द ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम आइडेंटिफाइड बाय अ यूनिक प्रोसेस
आईडी कॉल्ड पीआईडी। तो हर प्रोसेससेस का
एक पीआईडी होता है। प्रोसेस आईडी उसको
बोलते हैं। ठीक है? बस एक प्रोसेस आईडी
होता है जिससे कि उसको पहचाना जाता है,
जाना जाता है। ठीक है? तो यह एक फंडामेंटल
यूनिट है। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इसको मैनेज
करती है। मैं अगर यहां पे टास्क मैनेजर
में अगेन आपको दिखाऊं।
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं ये सारे
प्रोसेससेस हैं। मान लो। ठीक है? राइट
क्लिक करते हैं यहां पे। आप एक्सपेंड
करेंगे तो यहां पे ये एक्सपेंड हो के इसके
अंदर की जो चीज़ है वो चीज़ आ जाएंगी। यहां
पे यहां पे प्रॉपर्टीज पे जाएंगे तो इसकी
पूरी प्रॉपर्टीज आपको दिखेगी। यहां पे
डिजिटल सिग्नेचर की यहां पे जो भी है वो
दिखेगी। सिक्योरिटी का परमिशंस वगैरह
दिखेगा। यहां पे आपको डिटेल वगैरह जो है
वो इसकी पूरी डिटेल वगैरह दिखेगी सब कुछ।
एंड साथ ही में यहां पे जब मैं आऊंगा
लेट मी
कम टू द
हां डिटेल्ड यहां पे टास्क मैनेजर में
थोड़ा डिटेल वे में यहां पे आते हैं। इस
वाले ऑप्शन पे यहां पे डिटेल जब हम देखने
आएंगे तो यहां पे जितने भी यहां पे आपको
प्रोसेससेस चल रहे हैं उन सबकी यहां पे
पीआईडी आपको देखने को मिलेगी। जो भी
पीआईडी है प्रोसेस आईडी है। अब हर प्रोसेस
का एक यूनिक आईडी होता है। जितने भी
प्रोसेससेस आपके रन होते हैं दे गॉट एन
यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर ताकि हम उस आईडी से उस
प्रोसेस को पहचान पाए और उस आईडी से उस
प्रोसेस को हम किल कर सकते हैं या प्रोसेस
को खत्म कर सकते हैं। प्रोसेस को बंद कर
सकते हैं। ये सारी चीजें। राइट? अब यहां
पे इन प्रोसेससेस में आप देख सकते हैं कि
जितने भी यहां पर प्रोसेससेस हैं उन सब की
एक पीआईडी प्रोसेस आईडी मिली हुई है और
स्टेटस पता चल रहा है कि ये रन हो रहे हैं
कि नहीं हो रहे हैं कि रुके हुए हैं कि
सस्पेंडेड है क्या है ये सब आपको पता
चलेगा तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे chrome
exc ये देख सकते हैं ये एक मेरा यूजर
स्पेसिफिक सर्विस है प्रोसेस है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स नाम से अब यहां पे ये एक
सिस्टम के प्रोसेस अब देखिए यहां पे ये
सिस्टम प्रोसेस है ज इसका आगे सिस्टम लिखा
हुआ ये सारे सिस्टम प्रोसेस है। ये
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के प्रोसेस है। मतलब एक यूजर
स्पेसिफिक प्रोसेस है। एंड यहां पे आपके
ये सिस्टम प्रोसेस है। अब यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे एक लोकल सर्विस चल रही
है। यहां पे niss ssrv.exc ये एक अलग
प्रोसेस है। बट जितने भी प्रोसेस है सबकी
एक पीआईडी प्रोसेस आईडी जो है वो दी हुई
है। एंड इस प्रोसेस आईडी के थ्रू इसको
आइडेंटिफाई किया जाता है। ये प्रोसेस आईडी
जो है वो बिल्कुल यूनिक होते हैं। दीज़ आर
टोटली यूनिक प्रोसेस आईडी। सारे प्रोसेस
Chrome के अगर चार पांच प्रोसेससेस चल रहे
हैं तो चारों पांचों के प्रोसेस आईडी
डिफरेंट होंगे। ऐसा नहीं कि सेम होगा एक
अगर एप्लीकेशन का एक एप्लीकेशन के अगर 10
प्रोसेस चल रहे हैं तो 10 के 10
प्रोसेससेस के प्रोसेस आईडी अलग-अलग
होंगे। ठीक है? आर यू गेटिंग इट? समझ में
आ रहा है सबको?
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस?
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? प्लीज लेट मी नो।
यस। ओके। ओके। बढ़िया। प्रोसेस इज अ रनिंग
प्रोग्राम विद प्रोसेस एक रनिंग प्रोग्राम
होता है जिसमें एक पीआईडी होती है,
प्रोसेस आईडी होती है जिसके मेमोरी होते
हैं और थ्रेड्स होते हैं। ठीक है? ये
प्रोसेससेस होते हैं। अच्छे से। बढ़िया।
अच्छी बात है। अच्छे से समझना अच्छी बात
है। चलिए अब आगे चलते हैं। अब यहां पे कुछ
मस्ट नोन सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस हैं जिसको मैं
आपको यहां पे बताऊंगा। जैसे कि एक प्रोसेस
होता है sms.exe
sms sms.exee
ये क्या होता है? ये फर्स्ट यूजर मोड
प्रोसेस होता है। जैसे यूजर मोड में जो
सबसे पहला प्रोसेस होता है वो होता है
sms.exec
एक होता है विन init.exee windows init ये
आपके सिस्टम को स्टार्ट करने वाली प्रोसेस
होती है। विन इन init इसको आप विन इनट मत
पढ़ लेना। ठीक है? या वी इनट मत पढ़ना। ये
होता है विन इनट। Windows को इनिशिएट करने
वाला प्रोसेस। ठीक है? तो ये सिस्टम को
स्टार्ट करता है। दिस इज़ दिस प्रोसेस।
सर्विसेस exces.exe
क्या होते हैं? जितने भी सर्विसेस होते
हैं आपके Windows के अंदर में उन सर्विसेस
को मैनेज करता है। एवरीथिंग मैनेज करता
है। ठीक है?
थ्रेड्स इन ओएस क्या-क्या यूज़ होगा?
थ्रेट्स का मतलब होता है बेसिकली अह अह
देखो थ्रेड का मतलब होता है कि एक
पर्टिकुलर टाइम में कितनी चीजों को एक साथ
किया जा रहा है। तो एक प्रोसेस जो है वो
एक पर्टिकुलर टाइम में जैसे आपका प्रोसेसर
होता है वो मल्टीपल प्रोसेससेस को
एग्जीक्यूट करती है। मल्टीपल प्रोसेससेस
एग्जीक्यूशन होता है। एंड एक टाइम फ्रेम
में क्या होता है उस केस में कि अगर
थ्रेड्स ज्यादा यूज हो रहे हैं तो वहां
मल्टीपल प्रोसेससेस को एक बार में वो
हैंडल करेगा आपका प्रोसेसर मल्टीपल काम को
ऐसा बोल सकते हैं कि अगर आप एक काम के लिए
आप किसी एक काम एक काम को कभी-कभी आप दो
लोगों से करा रहे हो कभी-कभी आप 10 लोगों
से करा रहे हो तो 10 लोगों से पैरेलली
कराओगे वो काम आपका जल्दी होगा एफिशिएंट
होगा फास्टर होगा दो लोगों से कराओगे
थोड़ा टाइम लेगा तो दैट इज़ द थ्रेड
थ्रेड्स होते हैं बग बंटी में भी थ्रेडिंग
आपने पढ़ी होगी थ्रेडिंग थ्रेड्स का यूज़
करना। राइट? तो, यह तो उसमें भी सेम ही
चीज़ है। कुमार रतेश अरे रतेश
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] कैसे
हो ब्रदर?
ओके।
सर्विसेस जो सर्विज को मैनेज करते हैं।
एलsxc एलs जो है वह बेसिकली ऑथेंटिकेशन
एंड क्रेडेंशियल्स को मैनेज करता है। एलsस
जो है सिक्योरिटी को मैनेज करता है। आप
बोल सकते हैं जो भी विंडोज़ में आप लॉग इन
वगैरह करते हैं वो सब एलsस मैनेज करता है।
अटैक की हम बात करें तो mmc जैसे टूल यूज़
कर सकता है कोई अटैकर और क्रेडेंशियल्स को
डंप कर सकता है। एंड दैट इज़ दैट इज़ इट। तो
यह अटैक इस तरह के अटैक्स वगैरह कर सकते
हैं जो अटैकर्स होते हैं। राइट?
ऑलाइट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आर यू गेटिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] गाइस
बता दीजिए मुझे एक बार बता बता दीजिए
फटाफट बताइए
सर आप पहले से प्यारे हो गए हैं। क्या राज
है इसका? अरे कौन हो भाई?
अरे यार तो तारीफ कर रहे हो तो नाम तो
बताओ एटलीस्ट कम से कम। थैंक यू वेरी मच।
ओके।
अभी सभी लोग लाइक ठोक देना। फटाफट लाइक
ठोक देना। समझ में आ गया? ठीक है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यस एलsस जो है उसमें वलेबिलिटी हो सकती
है। पास्ट में एलsस को एक्सप्लइट भी किया
गया है। एंड पास्ट में Windows XP की अगर
मैं बात करूं तो वहां पूरा का पूरा एल्स
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाता था एक एक्सप्लइट के
थ्रू। एंड Windows XP में बिना पासवर्ड के
भी लॉग इन हो जाती थी। या कोई भी रैंडम
पासवर्ड डाल के भी लॉग इन होता था। दैट
वाज़ द एक्सप्लॉयटेशन ऑफ़ एल्स।
ठोक दिया। बहुत अच्छी बात है। उसी में एक
प्रोसेस होती है svc होस्ट.exc जितने भी
होस्ट सर्विसेस हैं जो आपकी Windows रन
करती है उन सबको मैनेज करता है sbc
होस्ट.exc तो एसओसी के लिए अगर आपका क्या
आपको क्या समझ में आना चाहिए यहां पे कि
मैलवेयर्स जो है वो यहां पे हिडन होते
हैं। sbc होस्ट.exc नाम से कई सारे
मैलवेयर्स पास्ट में आए हैं। वायरसेस
पास्ट में आए हैं। जो एसओसी होस्ट नाम से
खुद का एक डुप्लीकेट प्रोसेस बना लेते हैं
और वहां पे हाइड हो जाते हैं और बाद में
आपको दिक्कत करते हैं। मल्टीपल एस एसबीc
होस्ट.exc आपको प्रोसेससेस देखने को मिल
सकते हैं। ऐसा ये वाली जो टेक्निक है कई
सारे मैलवर्स ने पास्ट में यूज़ किया है।
तो ये होस्ट सर्विज के लिए होते हैं। तो
आसान होता है। थोड़ा सा इजी होता है।
राइट?
ओके। एसोसिएट डिटेक्शन की बात करें तो
यहां पे जैसे कि मान लो यहां पे कि विनर्ड
excinx
एक वर्ड का नेम है फाइल नेम है उस उसको
कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया फिर पावर सेल
एग्जीक्यूट किया देन वहां पे कमांड्स
एग्जीक्यूट किया जैसे मैंने पहले ही बताया
था कि यहां पे जो वर्ड का वर्ड का माइक्रो
यहां पे एक एक्सप्लइट था देखो
वर्ड माइक्रो
एक्सप्लइट
कुछ इस तरीके से आप इसको थोड़ा सा पढ़
लीजिएगा। यू कैन यू कैन रीड इट थ्रू या आप
इस तरीके से रैपिड से का भी जो है इसको भी
आप जा सकते हैं यहां पे। यह बेसिकली 2018
में क्रिएट हुआ था। 2012 में डिस्क्लज़
किया गया था इसको। अब अह यू कैन सी दिस
मॉड्यूल इंजेक्ट समिलिसिस माइक्रो इंटू
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट। द
कमेंट्स फेल्ड इन द मेटा इज़ इंजेक्टेड विथ
द बेस 64 इंक्रिप्टेड पेलोड। व्हिच विल बी
डिकोडेड बाय द माइक्रो एग्जीक्यूटेड एज अ
Windows एग्जीक्यूटेबल। एग्जीक्यूटेबल की
तरह ये एग्जीक्यूट होता था यहां पे। एंड
बेसिकली जो क्या होता था द विक्टिम जो है
वो बेसिकली क्या होता था कि पूरे उसके
कंप्यूटर का जो है वो कॉम्प्रोमाइज उसके
कंप्यूटर को कर लिया जाता था इसके थ्रू।
मेटास्प्लॉयड का एक फ्रेमवर्क भी है यहां
पे जो एक्सप्लइट ऑलरेडी मेटास्प्लॉयड में
प्रेजेंट है जो कि मल्टी फाइल फॉर्मेट
ऑफिस वर्ड मैक के फॉर्म में है। इसको भी
यूज़ किया जाता है अटैक पर्पस को दिखाने के
हालांकि आप हैकिंग के स्टूडेंट नहीं है तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है आई एम नॉट गोइंग थ्रू
दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग। इतना डिटेल और टेल
में कुछ जरूरत नहीं है। बट स्टिल मैंने
आपको बताया आप थोड़ा जानकारी चाहिए तो आप
ले सकते हैं जानकारी। ठीक है? तो इस तरीके
से एसओसी डिटेक्शन की बात है यहां पे
अटैक्स होते हैं इस तरीके से। राइट? अब
चलते हैं। अब यहां पे Windows अभी हमने
Windows प्रोसेस आर्किटेक्चर देखा। हमने
जहां पे प्रोसेस क्या होते हैं? पीआईडी
क्या होता है? ये सब देखा। कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
प्रोसेससेस को देखा। अब यहां पे आते हैं
Windows मेमोरी आर्किटेक्चर में। तो
मेमोरी आर्किटेक्चर में कुछ भी नहीं है।
एक वर्चुअल मेमोरी की हम बात करते हैं
यहां पे जो कि ईच प्रोसेससेस गेट्स
आइसोलेटेड मेमोरी। जो मैंने पहले ही
डिस्कस किया था कि जितने भी प्रोसेससेस
होते हैं उनको एक मेमोरी मिलता है। उसी
मेमोरी में उनको काम करना होता है। तो
एसओसी थ्रेड्स के लिए क्या हो सकता है कि
प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन का एक अटैक होता है। वो
हो सकता है। डीएलएल इंजेक्शन अटैक हो सकता
है। फाइललेस मैलवेयर्स हो सकते हैं जो
बेसिकली एग्जैक्टली फाइल नहीं है बट
मेमोरी के अंदर में काम कर रहे हैं।
मेमोरी के अंदर में अपने आप को हाइड करके
रखा हुआ है। एंड वो ऑपरेट कर रहे हैं। ऐसे
मैलवेयर्स हो गए। डीएलएल डायनेमिक लिंक
लाइब्रेरी जो होती हैं उनके अंदर भी काम
उनको उनके थ्रू भी यह एग्जीक्यूट हो सकते
हैं। उनफेक्ट कर सकते हैं। प्रोसेससेस को
इनफेक्ट कर सकते हैं। एंड देन दे कैन
इनफेक्ट एंड एंड दे कैन एक्सप्लइट द
सिस्टम। सिस्टम को कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया जा
सकता है। ठीक है?
अ आर्टिफिशियल इंटेलिजेंस इनको भी टाइम
आउट करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि इन्होंने काफी
स्पैम कर दिया। तो 10 मिनट का टाइम आउट
करते हैं इनको।
आई होप कि यह समझ में आ गया होगा। ये एक
वर्चुअल मेमोरी की बात है। इसमें ज्यादा
कुछ यहां पे नहीं है। अब यहां पे Windows
के ऑथेंटिकेशन फ्लो की बात करते हैं। पहले
Windows के ऑथेंटिकेशन फ्लो क्या होती है?
देखो होता क्या है? यूजर लॉग इन करता है।
एलsस के थ्रू ये चीजें मैनेज होती है। जो
आपका एलsस होता है। अ आपका बेसिकली
Windows के आर्किटेक्चर का पार्ट है आपका
या यू कैन से कि Windows के सिक्योरिटी
आर्किटेक्चर का पार्ट है एल्स। तो ये आपका
हो गया। एल्स के थ्रू ऑथेंटिकेशन होती है।
एंड उसके बाद एक्सेस टोकन एंड देन आपका जो
भी लॉगिन वगैरह होता है वो लॉग इन होता
है। तो जो आप Windows में लॉग इन वगैरह
करते हैं वो इसका पूरा प्रोसेस यही है कि
आप लॉग इन करने जाते हैं एल्स के थ्रू
ऑथेंटिकेट होके एंड देन आपका लॉग इन होता
है। ठीक है? एक्सेस टोकंस के अंदर में
क्या होता है? यूजर की आइडेंटिटी होती है
एंड प्रिविलेजेस होती है। जो एक्सेस टोकन
यहां पे आपका विंडो जनरेट करता है। जब आप
जब भी आप Windows में लॉग इन करते हैं तो
जो एक्सेस टोकन है उसके अंदर
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन क्या होती है पता है? उसके
अंदर इनेशन होती है। आपकी आइडेंटिटी होती
है और आपका प्रिविलेज होता है कि भैया आप
एग्जैक्टली हैं कौन? जैसे मैंने अगर
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स यूजर से लॉगिन किया तो मैं
कौन हूं और मेरी क्या प्रिविलेजेस है। तो
मान लो कि मैं अगर सीएमडी ओपन कर लूं।
प्लीज फोकस हियर। मैं यहां पे नेट यूजर
एंटर करूंगा। तो यहां पे यूज़र्स की लिस्ट
आएगी। यहां पे कौन-कौन से यूज़र्स हैं। तो
मान लो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है,
डिफ़ॉल्ट अकाउंट ये सब है। यहां पे गेस्ट
है। एक डिफ़्रॉनिक्स यूजर भी है। राइट? तो
अगर मैं डिफ़्रॉनिक्स बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट मैं
डिफ़्रोनिक्स को यूज़ करता हूं। बीइंग एन
मेन यूजर। तो मैं डिफ़्रॉनिक्स से लॉग इन
कर रहा हूं। तो इस इस पर्टिकुलर टोकन के
अंदर में इनेशन क्या होगी कि भैया
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स की कौन है? ये यूजर कौन है?
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स है और उसकी क्या प्रिविलेजेस
है? वो नॉर्मल यूजर है, एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
यूजर है या क्या है? तो मेरा ये एक
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर है। तो सारी
प्रिविलेज देने सब अलाउड रहेगा। सब कुछ
उसको मिलता रहेगा। तो ये सारी चीज़ होती है
टोकन के अंदर में। तो एसओसी को बीइंग एन
एसओसी एल1 आपको क्या ध्यान रखना है कि
भैया टोकन की चोरी ना हो जाए क्योंकि टोकन
चोरी कर ली जाएगी या टोकन गेस कर लिया
जाएगा टोकन होगा अटैकर के पास तो उस केस
में क्या होगा कि पूरा सिस्टम आपका
कॉम्प्रोमाइज प्रिविलज्लेशन होगी सिस्टम
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होगा सिस्टम अटैक होगा ये
सारी चीज़ हो जाएगी राइट गॉट इट
सर मुझे बग क्राउड में बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम
पे $2000 की बाउंट्री मिली है आपको
Twitter पे टैग किया आपने रिप्लाई नहीं
दिया है। Twitter मैंने ध्यान नहीं दिया
होगा। कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू फॉर 2000
ह्यूज डॉलर बंटी। एंड आई होप कि आप ऐसे ही
आगे बढ़ते जाइए एंड और भी बंटीज लीजिए।
मेनी मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू। अपना नाम
भी बता दीजिए ताकि मुझे पता रहे कि आपका
नाम क्या है। राइट?
बहुत अच्छी बात है।
ओके। गॉट इट। ये Windows का ऑथेंटिकेशन
फ्लो है हमारे भैया। जहां पर हम एक्सेस
टोकन, एलएस इन सब की बात करते हैं। राइट?
अब यहां पर हम बात करते हैं। अब हम आते
हैं Windows की रजिस्ट्री पे। ठीक है? अब
हम [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां
आएंगे Windows की रजिस्ट्री पे। इसको थोड़ा
सा ध्यान दीजिएगा। इस पे थोड़ा ध्यान देके
देखिएगा क्या एक्सक्टली होता है। Windows
रजिस्ट्री किस तरीके से काम करता है। ये
सब कुछ आपको पता चलेगा। राइट?
ओके। यहां तक सब समझ में आ गया आपको?
Windows आर्किटेक्चर में सब समझ में आ
गया? बता दीजिए मुझे।
बक बाउंड्री की प्लेलिस्ट देखो बिल्कुल
देखो
क्लियर है सबको एक बार प्लीज लेट मी नो
जल्दी बता दीजिए सभी लोग
रिप्लाई करने में यार बहुत डरते हैं आप
लोग।
करेक्ट। बग बाउंट की सीरीज अच्छी है।
कंसिस्टेंसी के साथ होनी चाहिए। राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बिल्कुल सही
बोला आपने। आदित्य सिंह ने बिल्कुल सही
बोला है कि कंसिस्टेंसी के साथ अगर आप हैं
तो आपको मजा आएगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? Windows रजिस्ट्री की अब हम यहां
पे बात करते हैं। लेट्स कम ऑन द Windows
रजिस्ट्री पार्ट।
आई होप कि आपको अभी तक Windows
आर्किटेक्चर में सब कुछ समझ में आ गया
होगा। देखा आपने कैसे हम प्रोटेक्शन रिंग
की बात कर रहे थे। रिंग ज़ीरो से रिंग थ्री
की बात कर रहे थे। रिंग ज़ीरो सबसे ज्यादा
प्रिविलेज रिंग थ्री लिस्ट प्रिविलेज।
रिंग ज़ीरो कर्नल मोड होता है। रिंग थ्री
जो है वो यूजर मोड होता है। रिंग ज़ीरो में
कर्नल एग्जीक्यूटिव सर्विज जैसे डिवाइस
ड्राइव ड्राइवर्स HL हार्डवेयर
इंस्ट्रक्शन लेयर जो हार्डवेयर को
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से कनेक्ट करते हैं। ये
सब ऑपरेट करते हैं। एंड रिंग थ्री के अंदर
में आपके जो डायनेमिक लिंक लाइब्रेरीज़
हैं, यूज़र्स के एप्लीकेशनेशंस हैं, सिस्टम
जो सर्विसेस हैं, प्रोसेससेस जो बेसिकली
हैं, वो सब कुछ ऑपरेट करते हैं। ठीक है?
ये मैंने आपको सब कुछ क्लियर कर दिया था।
यहां पे यूजर मोड में अ क्या-क्या चीजें
रन होती हैं? कर्नल मोड में क्या-क्या
होते हैं? रेस्ट्रिकशंस क्या है? एसओसी का
रेलेवेंस क्या है? ये सब कुछ मैंने बताया
था। देन Windows कर्नल के बारे में मैंने
आपको बताया। देन एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर्स के
कुछ लेयर्स के बारे में बताया मैंने।
हालांकि बहुत सारे होते हैं चीजें।
एग्जीक्यूटिव लेयर में आपको मैं एक्सप्लोर
करने के लिए बोलूंगा कि प्लीज गो एंड
एक्सप्लोर खुद से भी। बट कुछ-कुछ चीजें
मैंने बता दी। जैसे प्रोसेस मैनेजर,
मेमोरी मैनेजर, आईओ मैनेजर, सिक्योरिटी
रेफरेंस मॉनिटर ये सब कुछ आपको मैंने
बताया।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इसके बाद हमने हार्डवेयर एब्स्ट्रैक्शन
लेयर जो बहुत बार हम देख रहे थे HL
Windows के कोर कंपोनेंट्स में आता है
आपका उसके बारे में देखा कि HL क्या होता
है? डिवाइस के ड्राइवर्स क्या होते हैं?
देन हमने Windows की प्रोसेस आर्किटेक्चर
के बारे में पढ़ना शुरू किया। Windows के
प्रोसेससेस के बारे में पढ़ा। क्या होती
है? प्रोसेससेस पीआईडी क्या होती है?
मेमोरी वगैरह क्या होती है? थ्रेड्स वगैरह
क्या है? ये सब कुछ देखा। कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
जो आपके सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस होते हैं वो सब
देखा। जैसे एसएम एसएमएसएस हो गया। विन आई
यूनिट विन यूनिट वगैरह हो गया। सर्विसेस
हो गई, एलsस हो गया, एसबीसी होस्ट हो गई।
ये सब के बारे में हमने देखा। वर्चुअल
मेमोरी एग्जैक्टली क्या होता है? जो
प्रोसेसर्स को मेमोरी मिली होती है, उसके
बारे में हमने देखा। वही हम वर्चुअल
मेमोरी उसी को बोलते हैं। एंड उसके बाद
हमने Windows ऑथेंटिकेशन फ्लो देखा जहां
पे हमने एल्स का यूज़ देखा कि यूजर लॉग इन
करता है एल्स के थ्रू। टोकन जनरेशन होती
है। और टोकन में क्या होता है? यूजर की
आइडेंटिटी प्रिविलजेस होती है। एंड देन
ऑथेंटिकेशन होता है एंड लॉग इन वगैरह होता
है। अब हम यहां पे आ जाते हैं कि Windows
रजिस्ट्री क्या होती है?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आई लव यू सर। मुझसे शादी करेंगे। अरे भाई
कौन है यार ये सब
एलजीवी क्यों?
नहीं भाई नहीं करना है। नहीं करना है।
नहीं नहीं इलेक्ट्रो वायरस आप बिल्कुल आप
देखो आप वीडियोस वगैरह बना सकते हैं सब
कुछ कर सकते हैं लेकिन आप हमारी पीडीएफ को
यूज़ नहीं कर सकते हैं या पीपीटी को यूज़
नहीं कर सकते इट्स इट्स नॉट अलाउड
आप खुद की बनाइए ना खुद की बनाइए ना आप
खुद की क्यों नहीं बनाए आप खुद की बनाइए
यार हद है
अरे वह लड़का ही है।
बिलियन गर्ल जो है ना वो लड़का ही है जो
बोल रहा है शादी करने के लिए।
अरे भाई पता नहीं कहां-कहां से दिमाग में
क्या-क्या चीजें लाते हैं लोग। क्या-क्या
चीजें होती हैं। समझ नहीं आता कुछ। चलिए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
करेक्ट। करेक्ट। पीडीएफ को आप रेफरेंस के
तौर पे रखिए एंड आप उसको यूज़ नहीं कर
सकते। हैं बट रेफरेंस के तौर पे रख के खुद
का पीडीएफ खुद का बना के नोट्स बना के आप
कीजिए नॉट एन इशू। अब Windows रजिस्ट्री
की बात करते हैं। तो व्हाट इज़ Windows
रजिस्ट्री? Windows रजिस्ट्री जो होती है
Windows के अंदर में ये सेंट्रल डेटाबेस
होता है आपका Windows के अंदर में।
सेंट्रल डेटाबेस इसको कहते हैं। क्या
स्टोर करता है? सिस्टम की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन,
यूज़र्स की सेटिंग्स एंड एप्लीकेशन का
डेटा। ये सब स्टोर करता है। Windows
रजिस्ट्री बहुत पावरफुल चीज होती है।
Windows रजिस्ट्री के थ्रू मल्टीपल चीजें
की जा सकती है। पहले बहुत पहले मतलब
Windows रजिस्ट्री के थ्रू अ जब
स्टार्टिंग में मैं चीजों को सीखता था,
पढ़ता था तो हम लोग अलग-अलग तरह की
छेड़खानी करते थे Windows में। जैसे वेलकम
स्क्रीन पे कुछ लिख देना। जैसे Windows जब
ओपन हुई आपने लैपटॉप ओपन किया तो लॉक
स्क्रीन आती है। उस पे कुछ-कुछ चेंजेस कर
देना। उसप कुछ-कुछ चीजें लिख देना। ये सब
ये सब सारी चीजें छेड़खानी करना। कुछ एक
वेलकम वॉइस नोट एक स्टार्ट कर देना बैट
फाइल को एग्जीक्यूट करते हुए मल्टी वीबीएस
फाइल को देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट वी आर
डूइंग तो बड़ा छेड़खानी बहुत सारी चीजें
होती है ट्वीकिंग होती है वindows
रजिस्ट्री के थ्रू आप बहुत सारी तरह की
ट्विकिंग कर सकते हैं क्योंकि जितने भी
सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है, यूजर सेटिंग्स
हैं, एप्लीकेशन डेटा सब आपके Windows
रजिस्ट्री में ही आपके होते हैं। अब यहां
पे मैं आपको दिखा दूं Windows रजिस्ट्री
कैसी दिखती है। देखो, Windows रजिस्ट्री
को खोलने के लिए सबसे आसान तरीका है। अपना
Windows बटन प्रेस कीजिए। यहां पे टाइप
कीजिए रे डिट आर रेडिट रजिस्ट्री एडिट ठीक
है रेडिट टाइप कीजिए यहां पे आ जाएगा
रजिस्ट्री एडिटर इसको आप क्लिक करेंगे एक
बोलेगा यहां पे आपको यस अलऊ करने के लिए
अलऊ करेंगे एंड दैट्स इट आपकी रजिस्ट्री
खुल जाएगी ये है आपकी पूरी विंडोज
रजिस्ट्री अब आपको लगेगा कि अरे यार यहां
तो तीनचार फोल्डर दिख रहे हैं और क्या ये
तीन चार फोल्डर अपने आप में पूरी ये
सिस्टम की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन लेके बैठे हुए हैं
आपके पूरे सिस्टम की इसमें बहुत कुछ होता
है और अगर आपको ज्यादा आईडिया नहीं है।
ज्यादा पता नहीं है रजिस्ट्री के बारे
में। तो, इनके अंदर की जो सेटिंग्स और
चीजें हैं, उनको छेड़छाड़ मत कीजिएगा।
गलती से भी चेंजज़ मत कीजिएगा। अगर ना पता
हो, तो बिल्कुल मत कीजिएगा। क्योंकि उसका
इंपैक्ट यह पड़ेगा कि आपके नॉर्मल
फंक्शनैलिटीज जो है वो आपको कहीं ना कहीं
उसमें दिक्कत आएगी। Windows में अलग-अलग
तरह के इशूज़ आने स्टार्ट हो सकते हैं आपके
करने से। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गॉट इट? कोई बात नहीं। पाप लगने दो भाई।
पाप लगने दो बहना। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
बिलियनियर गर्ल।
आपका दिल कहां तोड़ा?
आप मेरी बहना बन जाओ। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
अब यहां पे देखिए तो यहां पे 1 2 3 4 5
चीजें हैं यहां पे। अब इसको जब एक्सपेंड
करेंगे ना तब आपको इसकी रियलिटी पता
चलेगी। जब एक्सपेंड करेंगे ये देखो। ओ माय
गॉड। एक एक चीज ये देखो कितना बड़ा है। ये
देखो।
ये देखो स्क्रॉल करते जाओ। ये तो पहला था
अभी। अभी फिर दूसरा है ये। इसको एक्सपेंड
करो। फिर इसमें फिर यह तीसरा है इसको
एक्सपेंड करो। फिर चौथा है इसको एक्सपेंड
करो। यह पांचवा है इसको एक्सपेंड करो।
इसके अंदर में भी एक्सपेंशन है भाई। यह तो
कुछ भी नहीं है। इसके अंदर फिर एक्सपेंस
एक्सपेंड करो। जैसे अब ये रहा अब से
सॉफ्टवेयर है। इसको एक्सपेंड करो। सारे
सॉफ्टवेयर्स की लिस्ट यहां पे। तो देयर आर
मल्टीपल थिंग्स जो कि आप इसको एक्सेस करते
हैं। बट अब यहां पे हां छोटे पैकेट में
बड़ा धमाका है। बिल्कुल सही बोला। ये छोटा
पैकेट बड़ा धमाका है हमारा Windows
रजिस्ट्री। एग्जैक्टली
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
होता क्या है? देखो
बेसिक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हायरार्किकल चार्ट मैं यहां पे आपके सामने
रखा है मैंने। बेसिक हायरार्की क्या होती
है? विंडो रजिस्ट्री के अंदर में आपका
कंप्यूटर हो गया पहला रूट जो आपका
कंप्यूटर है। उसमें आपके हाइप्स होते हैं।
उनको हम हाइप्स बोलते हैं। कंप्यूटर में
आपके हाइप्स होते हैं। जो आपको मैंने यहां
पे दिखाया।
आप ऐसे भी एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। रजिस्ट्री
को आप एक्सेस ऐसे भी एक्सेस करते हैं।
Windows R प्रेस कीजिए। रन आपका रन वाला
जो डायलॉग बॉक्स है वो ओपन हो जाएगा।
Windows R के बाद। यहां टाइप कीजिए रेडिट
और एंटर कर दीजिए। तो आपकी रजिस्ट्री यहां
से भी ओपन हो जाती है। तो इस तरीके से ये
ओपन हुई है। मैं जो है ना मैंने जो
एक्सपेंड किया था उसको अनएक्सपैंड कर देता
हूं थोड़ा सा कुछ इस तरीके से। ठीक है? अब
आते हैं यहां पे। अब यहां पे हायरार्की
होती है। हाइब्स होते हैं। हाइप्स के अंदर
में ना मल्टीपल चीजें होती हैं। तो ये
सारी जो चीजें होती हैं जैसे एच की
क्लासेस रूट, एच की करंट यूजर, एच की लोकल
मशीन, एच की यूज़र्स, एच की करंट कॉन्फ़िग
ये हाइप्स के अंदर में आपके होते हैं।
इनको हम हाइप्स कहते हैं। मान लो ये
हाइब्स। दीज़ आर हाइप्स। तो, इसके
हायरार्की मैं आपको दिखाता हूं। उसी तरीके
से कंप्यूटर हो गया। हाइप्स हो गए। हाइप्स
के अंदर आपके एच की रूट, एच की यूजर, एच
की मशीन, एच की यूजर्स, एच की करंट
कॉन्फ़िग ये सारी जो होते हैं इनके अंदर
में फिर होते हैं कीज़। इनके अंदर में क्या
होते हैं? कीज़ होते हैं एंड सब कीज़ होते
हैं। कीज़ के अंदर होते हैं वैल्यू। की
वैल्यू का पेयर होता है बेसिकली। तो की के
अंदर क्या होते हैं? वैल्यूज़ होते हैं।
वैल्यूज़ में अलग-अलग तरह के वैल्यूज़ होते
हैं। अलग-अलग तरह के कीवर्ड्स के थ्रू
वैल्यूज़ होते हैं। एक आपका डीवर्ड होता
है, स्ट्रिंग होता है, बाइनरी होता है,
कीवर्ड होता है। ये वैल्यूज़ होते हैं।
जैसे बाइनरी के थ्रू हो गया इसको दिखाने।
इसको डिनोट कैसे करते हैं? वैल्यूज़
किस-किस फॉर्म में रह सकते हैं? तो ये
बाइनरी फॉर्मेट में रह सकते हैं। स्ट्रिंग
फॉर्मेट में होते हैं। ये एक डी वर्ड
फॉर्मेट होता है उसमें या कीवर्ड फॉर्मेट
होता है। इसमें रह सकते हैं। इसी तरीके से
ऑपरेट करते हैं। इसको मैं अगर लाइव दिखाऊं
तो जैसे मैं यहां पे करंट कॉन्फ़िग देख रहा
हूं। सिस्टम में सॉफ्टवेयर में देख रहा
हूं। फोंट्स में अगर मैं बात करूं यहां पे
तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके
की आपको दिख रही है यहां पे नेम हो गया
टाइप हो गया यहां पे डीवर्ड डीव टाइप है
ये एंड यहां पे ये डाटा हो गया जो भी डेटा
यहां पे है ये डेटा आपकी हो गई उसी तरीके
से सिस्टम में करंट कंट्रोल सेट इसको
एक्सपेंड करते हैं सर्विज को एक्सपेंड
करते हैं मान लो कोई भी इसमें आएंगे तो ये
भी डी वर्ड इस तरीके से अब मान लो यूज़र्स
पे आते हैं यहां पे मैं यहां पे करंट यूजर
इस पे आ जाते हैं कंट्रोल पैनल पे आ जाते
हैं अपीयरेंस डेस्कटॉप पे आ जाते हैं एंड
यहां पे विंडो मैट्रिक्स पे आते हैं। तो
यहां पे बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस यहां पे आपको
बहुत सारी जो चीज़ें हैं देखने को मिलेंगी।
तो आपको दिखेगा कि अलग-अलग तरह की चीज़
यहां पे कैप्शन फ़ॉन्ट, कैप्शन हाइट यह
सबकी एक वैल्यू है जो कि या तो बाइनरी में
है या तो डी वर्ड में है। ठीक है? एस जेड
फॉर्मेट में है। देयर आर मल्टीपल
फॉर्मेट्स जो आपके यहां पे होते हैं।
स्ट्रिंग फॉर्मेट होती है आपकी। तो जो भी
फॉर्मेट्स हैं डी वर्ड हो गया, स्ट्रिंग
हो गया, बाइनरी हो गया, कीवर्ड हो गया। इन
फॉर्मेट्स में इनकी अंदर की डिटेल्स होती
है। ये सारे फील्ड्स होते हैं जो अलग-अलग
तरह के फंक्शनैलिटीज़ को शोकेस करते हैं।
देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट दीज़ अह
कीवर्ड्स कंटेन कि एक जैसे एक कोई
फंक्शनैलिटीज़ है बेसिकली उसको उसके बारे
में ये बताती है। उसकी उसकी एट्रिब्यूट्स
के बारे में उसके फंक्शनैलिटीज़ उसके
एट्रिब्यूट्स उसके फीचर के बारे में आपको
बेसिकली ये बताते हैं। तो ये कुछ इस तरीके
से हायरार्की आपकी होती है। जिसमें क्या
होता है कंप्यूटर के अंदर आपके हाइप्स
होते हैं। हाइप्स में आपके यह सारे होते
हैं जो आपको यहां पे मैंने दिखाया था। एच
की क्लासेस रूट, यूजर, मशीन, एच की यूज़र्स
उन उनके अंदर कीज़ होते हैं। कीज़ की
वैल्यूज़ होती है और वैल्यूज़ इन फॉर्मेट्स
में आपके वहां पे स्ट होते हैं बाइनरी,
स्ट्रिंग, कीवर्ड, डीवर्ड इन सब चीजों
में। राइट?
गॉट इट?
बाबुल की दुआ लेती जा तुझको सुखी संसार
मिले। [हंसी]
तुम लोग इतने क्रिएटिव कहां से होते हो
यार? इंटरनेट पे क्रिएटिव लोग बहुत है।
देखो अभी किसी वो कोई बोल रहा था ना उस पे
वो किया है। बाबुल की दुआ लेती जा। तुझको
तुझको सुखी संसार मिले। [हंसी]
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ग्रेट। अच्छा डायलॉग था। बढ़िया डायलॉग था।
बढ़िया डायलॉग मारा ये डायलॉग मुझे भी
सीखना पड़ेगा। क्या है यह? बाबुल की दुआ
लेती जा तुझको सुखी संसार मिले। बाबुल
मतलब बाबुल फादर को बोलते हैं। बाबुल फादर
को बोलते हैं। मतलब पिताजी को चलो मतलब
मुझे पिताजी बना दिया उसका। सही है। भाग
भाग गया वो। ओके।
तो ये पूरी हायरार्की आपको समझ में आ गई?
या हायरार्की? आर यू गेटिंग दिस
हायरार्की? कुछ इस तरीके से विंडोज
रिस्ट्रिक हर होती है।
ओके। अब यहां पे उसी को मैं यहां पे
विजुअलाइज तरीके से थोड़ा सा दिखा रहा
हूं। यहां पे
देखिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे एच की आपको दिख रहा होगा। ये
हाइप्स हो गए आपके।
ये बेसिकली रूट कीज़ इनको बोलते हैं हम जो
मेन होता है। उसके अंदर जो नीचे वाली होते
हैं वो बेसिकली कीज़ आपके जो भी कीज़ वगैरह
हो गए वो हो गई। उसके अंदर अगर कोई होता
है सब की हो गया। उसके अंदर जो चीजें होती
है वो वैल्यू हो गई। जो वैल्यू सामने मैं
आपको दिखा रहा था वो आपकी वैल्यू हो गई।
तो इस तरीके से ये काम करते हैं। एक मेन
आपका रूट की होता है। फिर आपका एक की होता
है। एक सब की होता है एंड देन वैल्यू्यूज
हो गई। तो एक्सपेंड करते जाइए। मतलब एक
आपका मेन है उसके अंदर में चीजें हैं और
फिर उसके अंदर में सर्विज उसके अंदर में
डायरेक्टरीज़ हैं तो उनको हम ये बोलते हैं।
मेन वाले को रूट कीज़ देन कीज़ एंड देन सब
कीज़ एंड देन उसके साइड में जो उसके पूरी
की पूरी इंफॉर्मेशन उसके बारे में आपको जो
भी वैल्यूज़ मिल रही हैं बेसिकली या जो भी
व्हाटएवर इनेशन मिल रही है उसकी उसके वो
सारी चीजें जो है वैल्यूज़ कहलाती हैं। ठीक
है? फंक्शनैलिटीज़ के बारे में या
उसके जो भी बताते हैं उसके बारे में वो सब
वैल्यूज़ हैं। ठीक है? आर यू गेटिंग?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? समझ में आ गया? ठीक है। चलिए ये
विजुअलाइज हो गई। अब रजिस्ट्री स्ट्रक्चर
की बात जैसे कि मैंने बोला था। तो
रजिस्ट्री स्ट्रक्चर में मैं यहां पे आपको
दिखाता हूं। हाइव में एचकेएलएम एचके
सीसीयू, एच के सीआर, एचकेयू ये सब आपने
देखा हाईव क्या होती है? जैसे मैंने आपको
बताया था Windows टैब
यह
यह हाइव हो गई। यह सारे एच की क्लास रूट,
करंट यूजर, लोकल मशीन यह हव्स हो गई आपकी।
ठीक है? एंड यहां पर एचकेएलएम मशीन वाली
क्या होती है? सिस्टम वाइड। इसका मतलब यह
सिस्टम वाइड कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस कंटेन करता है।
एचकेसीयू करंट यूजर वाली जो होती है, करंट
यूजर की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करता है। यह आपका
फाइल एचके सीसीआर जो है फाइल के साथ
एसोसिएटेड होता है।
एच के क्लासेस रूट जिसको हम बोलते हैं। यह
फाइल्स के साथ एसोसिएटेड होता है। एचकेय
जो है सारे यूज़र्स के लिए होता है।
एचकेसीसी जो है हार्डवेयर कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस के
लिए होता है। तो ये हाइप्स हैं जिनके नाम
यहां पे लेफ्ट में दिए गए हैं। और इनका
मतलब ये किस चीज के लिए किसके
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस किसके एंट्रीज एंड इनेशन
होल्ड करते हैं। तो ये यहां पे इसका
मीनिंग दिया हुआ है। एच के एल एम एच की
सीवी ये किस-किस के लिए होते हैं देख
लीजिए। ये सब आप देख सकते हैं। तो एक हाइव
होती है। देन की होता है। देन सब की होता
है। देन उसकी वैल्यू होती है। जो मैंने
यहां पे पिछले डायग्राम में यहां पे आपको
दिखाया था। जो फोटो थी इसमें आपको क्लियर
हो गया होगा। राइट?
सर पक्का ना है। फिर मैं आखिरी बार पूछ
रही।
अरे भाई हां यार पक्का ना है तुम पहली बात
तो तुम बिलियनियर गर्ल नहीं हो बिलियर बॉय
हो तो तुम दूर रहो
करेक्ट
सर आई एम 16 इयर्स ओल्ड इन क्लास 10 कैन
आई लर्न दिस स्किल फॉर फ्यूचर बिकॉज़ आई
आल्सो वांट टू गो इन एसओसी बाय 20130
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल अ मिटू
जैसवाल अगर आप अभी से इतने
सिंसियर हो चुके हैं तो इससे अच्छी बात
कुछ नहीं हो सकती है। डेफिनेटली गो फॉर
दीज़ थिंग्स। लर्निंग एंड
नॉलेज लेने की कोई ऐसी कोई लिमिट एज नहीं
होती है। कब से स्टार्ट करना है, क्या
स्टार्ट करना है। अभी से स्टार्ट कर सकते
हैं आप।
साइबर Intel इज पेड ब्रो पेड है वह।
चलिए तो ये आप समझ गए रजिस्ट्री स्ट्रक्चर
इसका। ठीक है? बेसिकली रूट की जो होती है
जिसको हम हाई बोलते हैं वो रूट की होता
है। जैसे ये हाईव है ना ये हाईव जैसे ये
मैंने बोला था एच की क्लासेस रूट हो गई।
लोकल मशीन यूजर्स ये हाईव हो गए। इनको हम
रूट कीज़ बोलते हैं। उसके अंदर में कीज़ आते
हैं। फिर उसके अंदर में सब कीज़ आते हैं।
फिर उनकी राइट साइड में जो उनका पूरा अह
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन उनकी पूरी फंक्शनैलिटीज़ के
बारे में उनका जो एट्रिब्यूट बताता है वो
जो वैल्यूज़ उसको बोलते हैं। राइट? अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] रजिस्ट्री
काम कैसे करता है? उसको देख लीजिए। ये
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट है आज के इस टॉपिक का।
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज़ है। रजिस्ट्री काम
कैसे करता है? देखो व्हेन सिस्टम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बूट्स जब आप
सिस्टम को बूट करते हैं। Windows रीड्स द
रजिस्ट्री। Windows रजिस्ट्री को रीड करता
है। लोड द कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस। कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस को
लोड करता है। सर्विज को स्टार्ट करता है
एंड यूजर की सेटिंग्स को अप्लाई करता है।
तो आपका Windows रजिस्ट्री को रीड करता
है। जब आप सिस्टम को बूट करते हो तो
रजिस्ट्री से ही आपकी जो है सारी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन रीड की जाती है Windows की
तरफ से। कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस को उसी के अकॉर्डिंग
लोड किया जाता है। सर्विसेज को उसके
अकॉर्डिंग स्टार्ट किया जाता है और फिर जो
है यूजर सेटिंग्स को अप्लाई किया जाता है।
इस तरीके से आपका रजिस्ट्री काम करता है।
तो कोई भी अगर ऐप रन हो रही है तो ऐप जब
आपने रन किया तो वो रजिस्ट्री रीड होती
है। देन उसके अकॉर्डिंग कॉन्फ़िगरेशन लोड
होती है और वो ऐप उसी के अकॉर्डिंग फिर
काम करती है, रन करती है। ये पूरा
रजिस्ट्री का गेम है। दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
अब इसका मतलब टाइप्स ऑफ़ वैल्यूज़ में क्या
होते हैं? वैल्यूज़ में अगर मैं बात करूं
रे एस जेड देखें तो स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू होती
है। जैसे हम देखा था हमने अभी रे डी वर्ड
है तो वो नंबर्स होते हैं। रे बाइनरी है
तो वो बाइनरी बाइनरीज़ फॉर्मेट में होता
है। डी वर्ड जो नंबर्स को कहते हैं।
बेसिकली नंबर फॉर्मेट में जो आपका होता
है। ठीक है? जो डेसिमल फॉर्मेट में बोल
सकते हैं। डेसिमल वर्ड बोल दो या डेसिमल
बोल दो। एस जेड आपका स्ट्रिंग के लिए हो
गया। बाइनरी के लिए आपका बाइनरी रेज
बाइनरी ये सब चीजें होती है। ठीक है?
करेक्ट करेक्ट नेक्स्ट जनरेशन काफी लकी
है। तो ये इस तरीके से रजिस्ट्री काम करती
है। बहुत इजी था समझने में। अब रजिस्ट्री
एंड अटैक्स की बात करें तो पर्सिस्टेंस
में हम बात करें तो पर्सिस्टेंस के लिए
यहां पे देखो एक लोकेशन होती है एच के
करंट एच के एच की करंट यूजर के बात करें
सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर में Microsoft के अंदर
Windows के अंदर में करंट वर्जन के अंदर
में रन ये एक लोकेशन होती है। यहां से
पर्सिस्टेंस वाली चीजें अटैकर्स करते हैं।
अगर इस लोकेशन पे रन वाली लोकेशन पे कोई
सर्विसेस अटैकर ने प्लांट किया है तो वो
सर्विज बार-बार जब भी Windows बूट होगी ना
तो वो सर्विज चलेंगी। जैसे मैं आपको यहां
पे चलते हैं HKCU में सॉफ्टवेयर Microsoft
में HKCU
में चलते हैं सॉफ्टवेयर में Microsoft में
चलते हैं।
ठीक है? एंड देन Microsoft के बाद हम चलते
हैं करंट वर्जन एंड रन में। ठीक है? मैं
यहां पे करंट वर्जन में चलता हूं। करंट
वर्जन में
हम हम [हंसी]
Windows एंटी करंट वर्जन एंड यहां पे रन
है आपका या नहीं है?
नॉट हियर
अच्छा एच के यूजर अच्छा यूजर वाले में ही
होगा करंट यूजर में बट ठीक है एक बार एच
के यूज में चलते हैं इसमें आई थिंक
हम हम
क्या देखते हैं इसमें तो होगा नहीं
सॉफ्टवेयर सर
यूजर्स चलते हैं डिफ़ॉल्ट
टॉप
Microsoft लेट्स से इफ देयर इज़
हम
कई बार अह लोकेशंस यहां पे चेंज Windows
NT के अंदर में कई बार चला जाता है। करंट
वर्जन यहां पे है। हां, करंट वर्जन में
यहां पे Windows पे चलते हैं। यह तो पेन
पेन वाला है डिवाइसेस। यह दिस इज़ आल्सो
नॉट देयर। Windows पे अगर हम चले तो करंट
वर्जन यहां पे मिलेगा।
ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके स्टार्ट यहां पे ये
स्टार्ट एक तो स्टार्ट मिला। ठीक है।
स्टार्ट में भी आप देख सकते हो। वैसे तो
बहुत सारी चीज़ यहां पे भी हो जाती हैं।
बहुत बात बहुत बात बहुत बात बहुत बात बहुत
बात बहुत बात बहुत बात बहुत बात बहुत बात
बहुत बात बहुत बात वी आर नॉट गेटिंग देयर।
वैसे मिलती है करंट यूजर में।
चलिए यहां पर देख लेते हैं एक बार सिस्टम
में। सॉरी सॉफ्टवेयर डायरेक्ट इसमें चलते
हैं Microsoft
एंड लेट्स गो टू द Windows NT Windows NT
में करंट वर्जन में आई थिंक देयर शुड बी
Windows L1
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
नहीं यहां पे नहीं यहां तो नहीं है
नहीं यहां पे एग्जैक्टली मिल नहीं रहा वो
लोकेशन नहीं मिल पा रही है लोकेशन मिल
जाती तो मैं आपको दिखा देता बेसिकली
लोकेशन मस्ट मे बी हैव चेंज्ड
लोकेशन थोड़ी बहुत चेंज होगी बट मिलना तो
चाहिए एटलीस्ट
चलो डायरेक्ट हम उसमें चलते हैं।
अ करंट यूजर में
सॉफ्टवेयर में ना जाके Microsoft में
Windows में करंट वर्जन में एक्सप्लोरर
में स्टार्टअप अप्रूव्ड स्टार्टअप
अप्रूव्ड में रन यहां पे है। ठीक है? हां
यहां पे है बेसिकली ये लोकेशन थोड़ा सा
चेंज्ड है। तो थोड़ा खोजना पड़ा ये बेसिकली
आप इस लोकेशन पे आ सकते हैं। कई बार देखो
कई लोकेशनेशंस आपके वही सेम होंगे जो
मैंने यहां पर आपको बताया ना यह लोकेशन ही
होगा।
HKU सॉफ्टवेयर Microsoft Windows
Microsoft के अंदर Windows फिर करंट वर्जन
एंड रन यह लोकेशन आपको मिल जाएगी। बट
स्टिल लोकेशनेशंस कई बार चेंज हो जाते
हैं। राइट? तो यहां पे अगर कोई रन वाले
यहां लोकेशन क्या है? यहां पे फिलहाल हमें
मिला Microsoft Windows करंट वर्जन
एक्सप्लोरर स्टार्टअप अप्रूव्ड रन। अब
यहां पे कोई भी सर्विसेस अगर अटैकर ऐड कर
देता है ना तो जैसे ही सिस्टम बूट होगा वो
सर्विस चलना शुरू हो जाएगा। जैसे ही
सिस्टम बूट होगा सर्विस चलेगा। यानी कि जब
भी आप कोई अगर कोई वायरस इनफेक्टेड भी है
आप सिस्टम को कुछ भी कर दें और फिर भी
सिस्टम जब स्टार्ट करेंगे तो यहां से वो
सेटअप स्टार्ट हो जाएगा और वो चलने लगेगी।
तो एंड जो वायर जो अटैकर्स होते हैं वो
क्या करते हैं? दे प्लांट मैलवेयर्स हियर।
वो मैलवेयर्स को यहां पे प्लांट कर देते
हैं। और यही रीज़न है जब मालवेयर हर एक रन
पे मैलवेयर एग्जीक्यूट होगा। हर एक बूट पे
मैलवेयर जो है वो एग्जीक्यूट होगा। दैट्स
इट। ठीक है?
ओके। यह तो अटैक्स है। ऐड कैसे करेंगे? यह
तो अटैक है यार। यह तो यही तो हैकिंग है।
यही तो हैकिंग होती है ना। वो तो हैकर
करेगा। राइट? रन वंस की। ये एक होते हैं
एग्जीक्यूट्स वंस यूज्ड बाय मैलवस। ठीक है
ना? तो ये रन वंस की होते हैं। जैसे कि इस
जगह पे आपको मिलेंगे एचकेएलएम मशीन वाले
में सिस्टम करंट कंट्रोल सेट सर्विसेस में
यहां पे मिलेंगे कि malvs को malvs
इंस्टॉल्स एज अ सर्विस। एज अ सर्विस जो है
यहां पे मैलवेयर को इंस्टॉल किया जाता है
रन वंस की के जगह पे रजिस्ट्री के अंदर
में एंड इस तरह के अटैक्स ल्च किए जाते
हैं जहां पे एज अ सर्विस मैलवेयर आपका रन
कर रहा होता है एंड वो ज्यादा खतरनाक हो
जाता है कि एज अ सर्विस उसको प्लांट कर
दिया गया है रजिस्ट्री के अंदर में एंड एज
अ सर्विस उसको Windows भी एग्जीक्यूट कर
रही है Windows सोच रही है ये तो सर्विस
है इसको एग्जीक्यूट कर दो एंड एक्चुअली
मैलवेयर एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा होता है एंड
आपका अटैक होता है wmआई पर्सिस्टेंस होता
है ये एक एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंस है जहां पे
अह wmआई एक प्रोटोकॉल एक यूटिलिटी है
Windows का जिसको यूज़ किया जाता है।
बेसिकली यहां पे देखो WMआम को अब
डिस्कंटिन्यू कर दिया गया है। वैसे तो
यहां पे मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। यहां पे
ये WMआई है। Windows मैनेजमेंट
इंस्ट्रूमेंट्स जो होते हैं
ये वाली चीज़ है। तो ये थोड़ा सा इसके कुछ
फीचर्स को डिस्कंटिन्यू किया गया है। वैसे
तो
अभी भी मतलब सपोर्टेड तो है ही बट कुछ-कुछ
चीजों को डिस्कंटिन्यू किया गया है। बट
स्टिल इट्स ऑप ऑपरेशनल। Windows मैनेजमेंट
इंस्ट्रूमेंटेशन होता है। ये क्या होता
है। यह एक इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है फॉर
मैनेजमेंट ऑफ़ डेटा एंड ऑपरेशंस ऑन Windows
बेड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स। तो अ ऑलदो यू कैन
राइट wmआई स्क्रिप्ट्स और एप्लीकेशनेशंस
टू ऑटोमेट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव टास्क ऑन रिमोट
कंप्यूटर्स। W आल्सो सप्लाईज़ अह मैनेजमेंट
डेटा टू अदर पार्ट्स ऑफ़ द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
एंड द प्रोडक्ट। तो बेसिकली क्या करते
हैं? Windows का एक मैनेजमेंट
इंस्ट्रूमेंट्स है। वहां से Windows की आप
मैनेजमेंट्स वगैरह जो है अह अह प्रोसेस
एग्ज़क्यूशन हो गया। स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू कोई
चीज़ एग्ज़क्यूट करना हो गया। ये सारी चीजें
होती है। तो स्क्रिप्ट एग्जीक्यूशन हो गई,
पर्सिस्टेंस बनाना है। तो डब्ल्यूएमआई के
थ्रू बहुत लोग बहुत अटैकर्स करते हैं
रजिस्ट्री का यूज़ करके। एंड वहां पे
बेसिकली क्या होगा कि एक स्क्रिप्ट के
थ्रू मैलवेस्ट एग्जीक्यूट होगी एंड
मैलवेस्ट जो है कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेगी। ठीक
है? तो रिप्लेस लेजिट पाथ। तो रेजिस्ट्री
के अंदर में लेजिटमेट जो पाथ होती है उसको
रिप्लेस कर देना। ये होती है आपकी
रेजिस्ट्री अटैक के अंदर में। ठीक है? ये
चीज़ होती हैं। ओके? ओके।
बहुत सारे [हंसी] ओके जस्ट वेट वेट अ
सेकंड गाइस आई एम कमिंग
ओके सो आई एम बैक। सो देखो अभी इन चीजों
इन चीजों को जो मैं आपको जैसे बता रहा हूं
ना ये जो चीजें हैं राइट ये चीजें आपके
लिए उस लेवल की अ आई होप कि मैं देख रहा
हूं देख रहा हूं ना
एम आई ऑडिबल एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए ऑडियो
वीडियो सही जा रही है आप लोगों को
सही है। ठीक है। ठीक है। तो ये जो चीजें
आपको बताई जा रही है ये आपको बेसिक्स आपकी
इनकी नॉलेज रखनी है। बेसिक्स नॉलेज आपके
पास होगी ना। एसओसी एल1 के लिए वही चाहिए।
बेसिक्स ऑफ एवरीथिंग। L1 प्रोफाइल के लिए
सिंपल सा फंडा है कि बेसिक्स नॉलेज ऑफ
एवरीथिंग ऑफ एव्री एस्पेक्ट ऑफ योर
कंप्यूटर नेटवर्क ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स बस
एंड फिर आपका एसआईएम और ये सब चीजें जो है
वो सब चीजें तो अपनी है ही। तो यहां पे
रजिस्ट्री अटैक्स में मैंने आपको
डब्ल्यूएमआई पर्सिस्टेंस के बारे में
बताया। रजिस्ट्री हाईजैकिंग होती है
जिसमें कि लेजिट पाथ को रिप्लेस कर दिया
जाता है। बेसिकली जो भी लेजिटमेट जो रियल
पाथ होती है सॉफ्टवेयर्स की एप्लीकेशनेशंस
की उनको रिप्लेस करके एक फर्जी पाथ पे वो
कर दिया जाता है। दिस इज़ रजिस्ट्री
हाईकिंग ऐसे भी होती है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] दिस इज़ काइंड
ऑफ़ अटैक्स जो होते हैं। अब इन अटैक्स के
बारे में अगर आपको जानना है तो ऑब्वियस सी
बात है। आप थोड़ा सा एक्सप्लोर कीजिएगा। बट
इतनी कुछ आपको रिक्वायरमेंट आपको नहीं
पड़ने वाली है। थोड़ी बहुत आईडिया अपने
खुद से एक्सप्लोर करके खुद से थोड़ा लाइक
सीख लीजिएगा। थोड़ा सा हल्काफुल्का नॉलेज
हो जाना चाहिए। एसओसी डिटेक्शन की बात
करूं तो क्या आपको मॉनिटर करना है? तो
सस्िशियस एंट्रीज मॉनिटर करनी है। जैसे कि
मान लो कि पावर शेलel.exc इन रन की यह
आपको दिख रहा है powerlे.exe चल रही है
भाई। चली हुई है रन वाले उसमें तो यह भी
बहुत अह दिस कुड बी अलार्मिंग अननोन
एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स रैंडम exec ऑटो एसेट कोई
अननोन एग्जीक्यूटेबल है वो ऑटोमेटिकली
स्टार्ट हो रहा है एज अ एसोसिएट आपको ये
चीज का ध्यान रखना चाहिए आपको अटेंटिव
रहना चाहिए इन चीजों के लिए अनयूजुअल
पाथ्स तो अब जैसे कोई अनयूजुअल पाथ है
जैसे ऐप डेटा टप के अंदर में कुछ एक
अनयूजुअल पाथ आपको मिल रहा है जो यूजुअली
नहीं होती है जनरली आपको देखने को मिलेगा
अरे यार कुछ अनयूजुअल है सिंपल सा मतलब है
यहां पे सिंपल सा
सिंपल सा बात है कि अनयुअल पाथ या अननोन
एग्जीक्यूटेबल या सस्पस एंट्री कुछ भी हो
एज एन एसओएल वन आपको ध्यान बस इतना रखना
है कि यू हैव टू
केयरफुली ऑब्जर्व एवरीथिंग जो भी सिस्टम
के ऊपर में अटैक्स या पोटेंशियल अटैक्स या
थ्रेट्स या जो भी चीजें हैं उस पे एकदम से
एकदम
फोकस्ड रहना है कि भैया क्या चीजें हो रही
है? हर चीज को अच्छे से आपको एग्जामिन
करना है। हर चीज को अच्छे से आपको गो थ्रू
करना है। एंड देखना है कि भैया कुछ उल्टा
तो नहीं लग रहा। किसी भी चीज में जिसमें
आपको थोड़ा उल्टा लग रहा हो। लग रहा हो कि
अरे यार ये कुछ तो गड़बड़ है। यहां कुछ तो
इशू है। वहीं पे आपको अपना काम अपना जो
अपनी जो स्किल है वो दिखानी है एसओसी की।
फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस बनना है और आगे
उसकी प्रोसेस करनी है। वो हम बाद में जो
क्लासेस होंगे आगे तो उसमें हम देखेंगे
कैसे-कैसे प्रोसेस करना है उन चीजों की।
राइट?
पक्का पक्का नहीं मैं जा रही नहीं रोकना
मुझे अब अरे हां जी जाइए भाई आप जाइए
बिल्कुल जाइए अब रजिस्ट्री फॉरेंसिक्स भी
होती है तो रजिस्ट्री फॉरेंसिक्स जो करते
हैं रजिस्ट्री फॉरेंसिक्स में क्या होती
है कि आप क्या-क्या एक्सट्रैक्ट कर सकते
हैं इंस्टॉल्ड सॉफ्टवेयर्स यूजर की
एक्टिविटी एग्जीक्यूशन हिस्ट्री ये सब
चीजें रजिस्ट्री फॉरेंसिक्स में
एक्सट्रैक्ट होती है कि कौन-कौन से
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल्ड हैं यूजर ने
क्या-क्या किया यूजर की एक्टिविटी और यूजर
ने क्या-क्या चीज़ एग्ज़क्यूट करी उसकी
हिस्ट्री ये सारी चीज़ें होती है। यह अटैकर
भी एग्ज़क्यूट अह चुरा सकता है। तो
रजिस्ट्री हैकिंग में जैसे रजिस्ट्री
फॉरेंसिक्स में चीज़ जो निकाल दी जा रही है
वो अटैकर भी आपके कंप्यूटर से निकाल सकता
है। चुरा सकता है। तो रजिस्ट्रीज़ आर
वेरीेंट। दैट्स व्हाई रजिस्ट्री आर वेरी
वेरीेंट। राइट?
चलो इनको टाइम आउट दे देते हैं। बिलियनियर
गर्ल बहुत ज्यादा इन्होंने स्पैम कर दिया
है। तो इनको 10 मिनट का टाइम आउट देते
हैं। सो दैट ये ज्यादा डिस्टर्ब ना करे
किसी को। ओके। अब Windows आर्किटेक्चर
प्लस रजिस्ट्री अटैक फ्लो को अगर हम देखें
कि Windows आर्किटेक्चर को और रजिस्ट्री
अटैक फ्लो को अगर हम कंबाइन कर दें तो ये
किस तरीके का दिखता है? फिशिंग हुआ। वर्ड
मैस एक्सप्लइट किया गया। पावर शेल से
एग्जीक्यू एग्जीक्यूशन हो रही है आपकी।
पावर शेल कमांड लाइन खुल गया आपका। वहां
पर पेलोड के एग्जीक्यूट किया गया। पावर
सेल के थ्रू भैया पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट हो गए।
रजिस्ट्री रन की को मॉडिफाई किया गया।
रजिस्ट्री में जो है जो रन वाली जो की है
जो बेसिकली जो मैंने दिखाया था थोड़ा देर
पहले रन वाली उसमें कुछ मॉडिफिकेशन की गई
ताकि बार-बार उसको स्टार्टअप पे चलाया जा
सके। उस उस सॉफ्टवेयर को या एप्लीकेशन को
पर्सिस्टेंस अचीव्ड। पर्सिस्टेंस जो है वो
अचीव हुई है। पर्सिस्टेंस अब हो गई
क्योंकि बार-बार वो लॉगिन पे चलेगी। तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है वहां पे पर्सिस्टेंस
अचीव हो गई। एल्स अटैक्ड अप पर्सिस्टेंस
हो गया तो एल्स को अटैक किया गया जो
सिक्योरिटी इनफोर्समेंट के लिए जरूरी होती
है। सिक्योरिटी इनफोर्स करने का सारा काम
Windows लॉग इन का उसी का होता है। तो
उसको अटैक किया गया। एंड देन जब आपके
लॉगिन हो गई या आपके पास एक्सेस हो गया तो
लैटरल मूवमेंट हो रही है। एक डिवाइस से
दूसरी डिवाइस दूसरी डिवाइस तीसरी डिवाइस
ये लैटरल मूवमेंट मैंने आपको नेटवर्किंग
वाली चीज में बताई थी। इसलिए बोला था कि
सब चीजें पढ़ना है। सब चीजें एक-एक
क्लासेस देखनी है। एक एक से एक क्लास से
दूसरा क्लास जो है अ एक दूसरे से कनेक्टेड
है। एंड कनेक्टेड हैं तो आप अगर अच्छे से
देखेंगे तो ही आप आगे की क्लासेस को अच्छे
से समझ भी पाएंगे। मैंने पहले ही बोला हुआ
था। राइट? तो अभी तो ये आपको क्लियर हो
गया होगा।
अब रजिस्ट्री फॉर एसओसी में बात करें तो
एक रियल एसओसी एग्जांपल देखें तो एक मान
लो इवेंट आईडी है रजिस्ट्री की मॉडिफाइड
ऐसा इवेंट आईडी है की एच के सीयू ऐसे करके
रन में हुआ है तो यहां वैल्यू है मैvx
इसका मतलब क्या हुआ पर्सिस्टेंस डिटेक्ट
हुआ है भैया पर्सिस्टेंस की तैयारी की गई
है पूरी पूरी पर्सिस्टेंस की जो है ट्राई
की जा रही है फाइनल एसओसी माइंडसेट क्या
है व्हेन एनालाइजिंग विंडो सिस्टम जब भी
आप एज अ एसओसी एल1 विंड सिस्टम को एनाल
एनालाइज़ करते हैं। तो क्या पूछना है आपको?
अपने आप से क्या पूछना है? व्हिच
प्रोसेससेस रन? कौन सी प्रोसेस रन हुई है?
व्हाट डिड इट मॉडिफाई? इसने क्या मॉडिफाई
किया? एनी रजिस्ट्री पर्सिस्टेंस? कोई
रजिस्ट्री में पर्सिस्टेंस का कुछ गेम तो
नहीं चल रहा। एनी क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस कोई
क्रेडेंशियल्स एक्सेस तो नहीं कर रहा। एनी
लैटरल मूवमेंट कोई लैटरल मूवमेंट एक
डिवाइस से दूसरे डिवाइस में नेटवर्क के
अंदर तो नहीं कर रहा। एज अ बीइंग एन एसओसी
एल1 आपको खुद से यह क्वेश्चंस करने हैं जब
आप Windows मशीन को एनालाइज करते हैं। जब
इनके क्वेश्चंस आप करेंगे और इनके आंसर्स
आपको मिलेंगे तो आपको क्लेरिटी मिलेगी कि
एग्जैक्टली हो क्या रहा है पूरे सिस्टम के
अंदर में एंड उसी क्लेरिटी के बेसिस पे आप
आगे एक्ट करेंगे और आगे की चीजें जैसे कि
आपका अल ट्राय एंड ट्रांसफर एग्जीक्यूशन
या जो भी चीजें हैं या उसको
फॉरवर्ड करना आगे ये सारी चीजें जो है
एस्केलेट वगैरह करना ये सब चीज़ आप करेंगे
तो ये सारा काम आपका होता है एज एन एसओसी
एल1 एंड ये थी हमारी Windows आर्किटेक्चर
एंड Windows रजिस्ट्री की कहानी जिसमें
हमने Windows आर्किटेक्चर का बेसिक समझा।
Windows रजिस्ट्री का बेसिक समझा। आपको
आर्किटेक्चर के बारे में पता चल चुका है।
Windows की रजिस्ट्री क्या होती है? कैसे
इसमें सारे सॉफ्टवेयर्स की एंड जितने भी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस हैं, उन सबकी एंट्रीज होती
है। उन सबके कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस होते हैं। सारी
चीजें यूजर की सेटिंग्स होती है, वो सब
होता है। एंड क्यों ये इतना इंपॉर्टेंट है
एज़ एन एसओसी? क्योंकि हटाकर इनको
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सकता है। एंड एन एसओसी
फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस आपका काम है इनको
डिफेंड करना। ठीक है? तो ये थी आज की
क्लास। आई होप कि आपको समझ में आ गई होगी
आज की क्लासेस। ठीक है? चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ओके। सबसे पहले
इसको मैं क्लोज करता हूं। एंड यहां पे मैं
बता देता हूं। जब भी आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखते
हैं जब भी आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखते हैं इन
क्लासेस की तो नीचे में यहां पे
रिकॉर्डिंग के ही नीचे में जब आप आएंगे तो
आपको हाइप का एक बटन आता है। नीचे में
देखेंगे हाइप लिखा होता है। तो हाइप के
बटन पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा। जितना आप हाइप
करेंगे पॉइंट्स उतनी ज्यादा YouTube
वीडियोस को रिकमेंड करता है। एंड बस लोगों
तक पहुंचती है। मैक्सिमम लोगों तक पहुंचती
है। दैट्स इट।
ओके।
चैट लिस्ट देखते हैं यहां पे।
ओके। सो
कौन है ये भैया? देख यहां सबके सामने मैं
दिखा दिखाता हूं। यहां पे सबके सामने मैं
दिखाता हूं। इन्होंने जो चैट में मैसेज
डाला था आई डोंट नो कि यह करेक्ट प्रोफाइल
है क्या है? अ यहां पे लिख रहे हैं ये माय
ओनली रियल अकाउंट Instagram
ज़रवाहा
ओके लेट्स सी हु इज
दिस पर्सन एक बार देख लेते हैं इन्होंने
मैसेज
इन्होंने जो चैट किया था।
सो लेट्स सी द आईडी।
इस नाम से कौन है भाई? किसका आईडी डाल
दिया यहां पर?
2 लाख कुछ किया है। अच्छा 2 लाख से
फॉलोवर्स भी हैं। ये कौन है यार? 2 लाख
फॉलोवर्स भी हैं। क्या बात है। अच्छी ये
तो रियल रियल आईडी लग रही है। दिस इज अ
रियल आईडी। बट आई डोंट नो कि इन्होंने
यहां पे कमेंट किया है। चैट की चैट में
इन्होंने आई थिंक डाला हुआ है। इन्होंने
क्या लिखा है? अब मैं ओरिजिनल अकाउंट से
कर रही हूं मैसेज। अ
टाइम आउट ना करेंगे। टाइम आउट नहीं। टाइम
आउट नहीं करेंगे। बिल्कुल टाइम आउट
बिल्कुल नहीं करेंगे आपको। टेंशन नहीं
लेना आपको। बिल्कुल टाइम आउट नहीं करेंगे।
बेफिक्र रहिए आप। ठीक है? आई विल बी नॉट
टाइमिंग आउट।
हां।
क्या लिख रहे हैं? अब मैं ओरिजिनल अकाउंट
से हैं। मैसेज कर रही पक्का नहीं हां जी
हां जी अभी भी नहीं है आपका ओरिजिनल
अकाउंट भी हो या जो भी हो यह आई डोंट नो
या व्हाटएवर आपका मे बी ओरिजिनल अकाउंट हो
बट यस पक्का नहीं डेफिनेटली नहीं थैंक यू
वेरी मच चलिए
ओके
नहीं आपको टाइम आउट नहीं करूंगा आपने
ओरिजिनल अकाउंट से मैसेज किया यहां पे तो
टाइम आउट तो नहीं करूंगा आपका वो फेक
अकाउंट है इसलिए टाइम आउट कर दिया था बट
आंसर इज़ अभी भी नो।
हां जी। हां जी। नहीं करनी भाई। नहीं
करनी। नहीं करनी यार। नहीं करनी।
ओके। सो सर वाईटी
हां वही बात है। वाईटी अरे सब फेक है।
मुझे सब पता है। आई नो एवरीथिंग।
मैं तो ये बोल रहा हूं कि रियल भी हो तब
भी नहीं तब भी कुछ नहीं है। तब भी ना है।
अब बताओ। अब नाउ अब अब आप चले जाओ। [हंसी]
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सर Lindin पर फेक हायरिंग पोस्ट होती है।
वह प्रॉब्लम है। जेन्युइन जॉब्स पर भी
विश्वास नहीं होता। हां बिल्कुल। Lindin
पे बहुत सारी ऐसी फेक हायरिंग पोस्ट होती
हैं। फेक हायरिंग चीजें होती है। देयर आर
मल्टीपल थिंग्स राइट।
बट आपको थोड़ा सा इन्वेस्टिगेशन करना
पड़ेगा। थोड़ा सा आपको नॉलेज उसकी इन लेनी
पड़ेगी।
अरे वो फेक आईडी होती है मिस्टर रोबोट।
ना नो नो नो हर जगह नो है भाई यश हर जगह
नो है।
इज दिस कोर्स गोइंग टू बी मेंबर्स ओनली?
हां आने वाले फ्यूचर में यह कोर्स मेंबर्स
ओनली हो जाएगा। एंड अभी यह फ्री है। बाद
में लोगों को परचेस करनी पड़ेगी यह कोर्स
देखने के लिए। एसओसी की हो गई आपकी बग
बंटी की हो गई। यह सब आपको परचेस करना
पड़ेगा। अभी जब तक फ्री है तब तक फ्री है।
आप इसको इसका बेनिफिट ले लीजिए एंड इसको
एंजॉय कीजिए। यहां पर मैं टॉप फैंस के
लिस्ट दिखा देता हूं यहां पे अगेन साइबर
जैन टेक डी। तो मैं सबके नाम तो नहीं बोल
सकता बट स्टिल आई एम शोइंग यू द टॉप 50
लिस्ट एंड ये लोग काफी एक्टिव रहते हैं
सेशन के दौरान। एंड आई एम ग्रेटफुल कि आप
लोग अपना टाइम देते हैं। एंड कुछ आप समझते
हैं कि या यू कैन लर्न एंड एवरीथिंग। तो
यह हैं हमारे टॉप 50 जो लोग हैं जो एक्टिव
थे यहां पे। चलिए अच्छी बात है। टॉप फैंस
की लिस्ट हमने देख ली है। एंड अब जो है अ
बेसिकली इस सेशन को यहां पे एंड करने का
समय आ चुका है। आई होप कि यू लर्न समथिंग।
आई होप कि आपने आपको मजा आया होगा। आपने
कुछ सीखा है। एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन
में बहुत जल्द क्योंकि नेक्स्ट सेशन फिर
इसके आगे कंटिन्यू करेंगे एंड वी विल बी
मीटिंग वेरी सून। ठीक है? तो तब तक के लिए
वीडियोस को शेयर जरूर कीजिएगा। चैनल पे
अगर आप नए आए हैं, नए हैं तो सब्सक्राइब
करके ऑल बेल नोटिफिकेशन ऑन कर लीजिए ताकि
नोटिफिकेशन आपको मिलती रहे। नोटिफाई आप
होते रहें एंड जो है आप जो है इसी तरीके
से लाइव क्लासेस अटेंड करते रहिए। सो दैट
कि आपको लाइव का वो मजा आ पाए। क्योंकि
लाइव में जो मजा है वो रिकॉर्डिंग में
बिल्कुल भी नहीं है। एंड शेयर कीजिए उनके
साथ जो एसोसिएट एंथूजियास्ट हैं जो पढ़ना
चाहते हैं, सीखना चाहते हैं फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट। जिनके पास उतनी अफोर्डेबल अ कोई वे
नहीं है जहां पे वो जहां पे वो पैसे उतनी
पैसे लगा के वो कोर्स खरीद सके एसओसी की
प्रिपरेशन कर पाए तो उनके साथ आप शेयर
कीजिए ताकि सबका भला हो सबका बेनिफिट हो
ठीक है
आई होप कि यू लर्न वेल ओके थैंक यू वेरी
मच गाइस एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट वीडियो में
नेक्स्ट क्लास में टाटा बाय-ब टेक केयर
गुड नाइट शुभ रात्रि